Hello! Or should I say ho ho ho? Say it! Say it! The holidays are here, you guys! It's like that time of year. Everything is happening. It's in full swing. And we're off this week, spending the holidays with our families. We hope you are having a wonderful one too. But we wanted to reshare one of our favorite holiday episodes with you. Yes, this week we are resharing Secret Santa. This reshare of the Office Ladies is presented by State Farm. Yes, the Secret Santa episode was such a blast to talk about. We hope this episode can bring you some more holiday cheer, so we partnered with State Farm to bring it back to the top of your feeds. Now listen, the holidays are time for fun, but there's also, you know, the top of your feeds. Now listen, the holidays are a time for fun, but there's also the possibility of little frustrating moments
大家好！或者我该说“霍、霍、霍”？说吧！说吧！节日到了，伙计们！就像一年中的那个时候。所有事情都在发生。正热火朝天地进行着。我们这周休息，和家人一起过节。希望你们也过得非常开心。但我们想和大家重新分享一期我们最喜欢的节日特辑。是的，这周我们重新分享的是《秘密圣诞老人》。这期重新分享的《办公室女郎》由State Farm呈现。是的，谈论《秘密圣诞老人》这一集真是太欢乐了。我们希望这期节目能带给你们更多节日欢乐，所以我们与State Farm合作，将其重新带回你们订阅源的顶端。听着，节日是让人快乐的时光，但也有，你知道的，订阅源的顶端。听着，节日是让人快乐的时光，但也有可能遇到一些令人沮丧的小时刻
like maybe your car gets damaged on your way to a holiday party or maybe your home gets damaged and oh my goodness, that can be so frustrating. I know one holiday we had a pipe burst underneath our floor. It's always when you least can handle it. It'll be like, oh, it's Christmas Eve and guess what, our toilet's overflowing. Yes.
比如你在去节日派对的路上汽车受损了，或者你的家受损了，天哪，那会让人非常沮丧。我知道有一个节日，我们地板下的水管爆裂了。总是在你最无法应对的时候发生。它会像是，噢，今天是平安夜，你猜怎么着，我们的马桶溢水了。是的。
Yes. And you know what, in those moments, you might wanna, you know, have some frustrating words. You might wanna say, oh my gosh, holy mistletoe. Well, holy mistletoe is a good one, but I've got another one for you, Ange. How about like a good neighbor, state farm is there? Yeah.
是的。你知道吗，在那些时刻，你可能想要，你知道的，爆出一些让人沮丧的话。你可能会想说，哦天哪，神圣的槲寄生。嗯，神圣的槲寄生是个不错的选择，但我还有另一个要送给你，安琪。就像好邻居，State Farm就在身边？是的。
Because even during the holidays, you can fill out a claim 24, 7 with state farm. You can file on the phone, online, or at the award-winning state farm mobile app. With a state farm agent, you know someone is there to help protect your future by helping you choose the coverage you need. So no need to throw out that holy mistletoe.
因为即使在节日期间，你也可以随时通过State Farm全天候填写理赔申请。你可以通过电话、在线或使用屡获殊荣的State Farm移动应用进行报案。有了State Farm的代理人，你知道有人在那里帮助保护你的未来，协助你选择所需的保险。所以根本不需要爆出那个神圣的槲寄生。
No. However you choose, like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. And now, here is Secret Santa. I'm Jennifer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you.
不。无论你如何选择，就像好邻居，State Farm就在身边。现在，以下是《秘密圣诞老人》。我是詹妮弗。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你独家制作终极办公室重温播客。
Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello Angela. Hi Jenna. You're fighting with a staple right now. I was hoping to have it done before the music stopped. No, you're still working on it.
每周，我们将剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有当时在场的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。你好，安吉拉。嗨，珍娜。你现在正在跟一个订书机较劲。我希望在音乐停止前把它弄好。不，你还在弄它。
Guys, I did this thing where I printed my document. You know, Jenna and I both do documents now, guys. I've moved on from note cards. I know, I don't know how I feel about it. I still have some posted notes, okay? Okay, good. Good. You know, post notes still happen.
伙计们，我做了一件事，我打印了我的文档。你知道的，珍娜和我现在都用文档了，伙计们。我已经不用便签卡了。我知道，我不知道自己对这有什么感觉。我还是有一些便利贴的，好吧？好吧，很好。你知道，便利贴还是会用到的。
And I color code everything, as you know, my document is all kinds of different colors. But this morning when I was printing it, I accidentally printed the font to size 40. It's so many pages. It's so many pages, it's like a phone book. And the staple would not staple it all. It wasn't it, it was poking me. Hi guys, welcome to office ladies.
而且我把所有东西都做了颜色分类，如你所知，我的文档有各种不同的颜色。但今天早上我打印的时候，不小心把字体设成了40号。页数太多了。页数太多了，就像一本电话簿。而且订书机根本订不上。它不对劲，它一直在扎我。嗨，伙计们，欢迎收看办公室女郎。
Today we're talking about secret Santa, but today in real life, it's St. Patrick's Day. It is. So we're kind of doing a holiday on a holiday. Mm-hmm. I'd like to say something before we get started. We have been together in the studio for 15 minutes so far this morning, and no one has mentioned my cute sassy new haircut.
今天我们聊的是《秘密圣诞老人》，但在现实生活中，今天是圣帕特里克节。确实是。所以我们有点像在节日里过另一个节日。嗯。在我开始之前我想说点什么。今天早上我们在录音室已经待了15分钟了，还没有人提到我可爱俏皮的新发型。
I noticed it right away when I was complaining about my printer issues. I know, but no one has complemented my hair. It looks very nice, I apologize. And I need the compliments. I'm fishing for the compliments. I thought you looked like a runway model when I saw you this morning. I said, who is that lady? She looks like a million f***ing bucks.
我抱怨打印机问题时立刻就注意到了。我知道，但没有人赞美我的头发。它看起来非常好看，我道歉。而且我需要赞美。我在钓赞美。当我今天早上看到你的时候，我觉得你看起来像个T台模特。我说，那是什么女士？她看起来像他妈的一百万美元。
And... Oh my god! It's my boss lady, Fringe, and a Fisher. Thank you. And you know what, setting it all off? What? Sassy haircut. Good.
还有……哦，天哪！是我的老板娘，齐刘海，还有费舍尔。谢谢。你知道吗，这一切的起点是什么？什么？俏皮的发型。很好。
It starts with the sassy haircut, and then it goes all the way down. You have a whole outfit. She has a little green stripey shirt, a cardigan, cute, cute accessories. I cannot tell if this is genuine, or if this is sarcasm, Sam, where do you stand on this?
从俏皮的发型开始，然后一直延伸到全身。你整套穿搭都很棒。她穿着一件绿色条纹小衬衫，开衫，可爱，可爱的配饰。我看不出这是真心实意的，还是讽刺，萨姆，你对此怎么看？
It's genuine. I think it's how I labeled it before. It's, I think it's genuine and hostile. It can be both. They said I came in hot this morning y'all. I came in hot. Angel of walked in, looked at the video camera so Cassie can see it and said no,
这是真心的。我觉得这就像我之前给它的定性。它是，我觉得这是真心实意的敌意。这两者可以兼得。他们说我今天早上来势汹汹，各位。我来势汹汹。安吉拉走进来，看着摄像机，好让卡西能看到，然后说“不”，
and tore it out of the wall instead of just asking to move it. They have this camera guy so we can be on Zoom with Cassie. And it literally, I don't know what evil person set it up today, but it was a shot under my neck and up my nose. And I was not good. It was not good. It wasn't. I'm gonna back you up on that.
直接把它从墙上扯了下来，而不是仅仅要求挪动一下。他们弄了这个摄像师，这样我们就可以和卡西进行Zoom通话了。老实说，我不知道哪个恶魔今天设置的，但它拍的角度是从我的脖子下方往鼻孔里照。这太糟糕了。太糟糕了。确实很糟糕。我要支持你的说法。
You know what, a woman who's just recently turned 50 doesn't need an under the neck shot. You know what it looks like? You know when you go on Instagram and you haven't angled the camera right yet, but it's on selfie mode. It's that horrifying moment where you see yourself from under the neck.
你知道吗，一个刚过50岁的女性不需要一个从脖子下方往上拍的镜头。你知道它看起来像什么吗？你知道当你上Instagram，还没把相机角度调好，但它正处于自拍模式。那种可怕的时刻，你从脖子下方看到了自己。
Yes. That's how the zoom camera was. So, yeah, Sam, I ripped it out of the wall. Angel, can I ask you a St. Patty's Day question? Oh, please. Will you be getting tutored today? That got my husband so tickled because my husband Josh listens to the podcast and I saw him when we all posted he was like, are we getting tuted, babe? All right, well, let's get into it. Okay. This is season six episode 13 written by Mindy Kaling, directed by Randalline Horn.
是的。那zoom相机就是这样的。所以，是的，萨姆，我把它从墙上扯下来了。安吉拉，我可以问你一个圣帕特里克节的问题吗？哦，请问。你今天会受到指导（tutor）吗？这把我丈夫逗乐了，因为我丈夫乔治听这个播客，当我们发帖时我看到他，他说，我们是要被指导（tutoed）了吗，宝贝？好了，我们切入正题吧。好的。这是第六季第13集，由明蒂·卡灵编剧，兰德尔·艾因霍恩导演。
This episode features a song from Green Day, and y'all know I'm friends with Billy Joe Armstrong, lead singer of Green Day. Jenna is blushing as she's saying this. She's blushing. I am such a fan of my own friend. It's true. I reached out and he agreed to read the summary. So here it is. Hello, office ladies listeners. This is Billy Joe Armstrong. Here's your summary for Secret Santa. It's Christmas time and Dund Mifflin. Jim and Dwight are in charge of this year's Christmas party and they are doing a pretty good job. Jim tells Phyllis she can play Santa, something she's wanted
这一集有一首来自绿日乐队的歌，你们都知道我和绿日乐队的主唱比利·乔·阿姆斯壮是朋友。珍娜说这话时脸红了。她在脸红。我是我自己的朋友的超级粉丝。真的。我联系了他，他同意朗读剧情概要。所以就是这样。哈喽，办公室女郎的听众们。我是比利·乔·阿姆斯壮。这是《秘密圣诞老人》的剧情概要。邓德米夫林迎来了圣诞节。吉姆和德怀特负责今年的圣诞派对，他们做得相当不错。吉姆告诉菲利斯她可以扮演圣诞老人，这是她多年来一直想做的事。
to do for years. This naturally causes Michael to spiral. Meanwhile, Oscar has a crush on a new warehouse worker and Pam plays matchmaker. Andy has Aaron in the secret Santa gift exchange, but so far it's not going well. She's mostly just been attacked by birds. There is some potentially devastating news from corporate hanging over everyone's heads, but in the end it's a great party with karaoke, a marching band, and even a little snow. Oh, a lonely room. We all walk alone, they're really. I mean, come on. Come on. He's the best.
这自然导致迈克尔情绪失控。与此同时，奥斯卡对一个新来的仓库工人产生了好感，帕姆则充当起了媒人。安迪在秘密圣诞老人礼物交换中抽中了艾琳，但目前进展并不顺利。她大部分时间只是遭到鸟类的袭击。每个人头顶都悬着来自总公司的一些可能具有毁灭性的消息，但最终这是一个很棒的派对，有卡拉OK、行进乐队，甚至还有一点雪。哦，一个寂寞的房间。我们都在孤单前行，真的。我是说，拜托。拜托。他是最棒的。
Come on. When he sang at the end, I was like, wow. We're all grinning. Oh, thank you. Thank you so much, Billy Joe. Thank you, Billy Joe. All right, fast fact number one, this episode aired on December 10th, 2009, but shortly afterward, there was an extended cut
拜托。当他在结尾唱歌时，我当时想，哇。我们都在咧嘴笑。哦，谢谢。非常感谢你，比利·乔。谢谢你，比利·乔。好的，趣味事实一，这一集于2009年12月10日播出，但不久之后，发布了一个加长剪辑版，
that was released, and it included nine extra minutes of footage, which brought the total length of the episode up to 29 minutes and 43 seconds. Oh, I have so much to share about this. I know you do. Okay, so there are no deleted scenes. If you have the DVD box set, there are no deleted scenes for Secret Santa. And it is because of this extended producer's cut. I guess there were so many great scenes they decided to make like our version back then
其中包含了额外的9分钟镜头，这使得这一集的总时长达到了29分43秒。哦，关于这个我有太多想分享的了。我知道你肯定有。好的，所以没有被删减的场景。如果你有DVD套装，《秘密圣诞老人》是没有删减镜头的。这是因为这个加长制作人剪辑版。我猜当时有太多精彩的场景，他们决定做出类似我们当年那种版本
of a super size, right? Yeah. So I reached out to Joy about for. You guys I've spoken about her before. She worked for NBC Digital and I was like, Joy, what did you know about this extended producers cut? And she said Angela, it was made for NBC.com. Oh, yes. And it was actually the first producers cut episode that they ran exclusively on NBC.com. Wow! That's right! A few more will come as we go through the seasons, but this is the full list of extended
也就是超大版，对吧？是的。所以我联系了乔亚关于。伙计们，我之前提到过她。她曾在NBC数字部工作，我说，乔亚，关于这个加长制作人剪辑版你知道些什么？她说，安吉拉，它是为NBC.com制作的。哦，是的。这实际上是他们在NBC.com上独家播放的第一集制作人剪辑版剧集。哇！没错！随着我们经历各季，还会推出更多，但这是NBC.com上播放的加长制作人剪辑版的完整列表，
producer's cuts that ran on NBC.com pretty quickly right after the episode aired. You could go to NBC.com and there they were. Secret Santa, Training Day, Search Committee, Angry Andy and Fund they were. Secret Santa, training day, search committee, angry Andy and fundraiser. Wow, and it was the first time we had ever done that. Of course now, all networks have websites and have episodes up there, but this was the first time it was ever done
在剧集播出后不久就上线了。你可以访问NBC.com，它们就在那里。《秘密圣诞老人》、《培训日》、《搜寻委员会》、《愤怒的安迪》和《募捐活动》都在那儿。《秘密圣诞老人》、《培训日》、《搜寻委员会》、《愤怒的安迪》和《募捐活动》。哇，这是我们第一次这样做。当然现在，所有电视台都有网站并且上面都有剧集，但这可是有史以来第一次为NBC、为我们的节目这样做。
for NBC, for our show. I wanna say, I feel like the folks at NBC.com were kind of trailblazers here. Yeah. Like they were creating really cool, extra content, original content, kind of before everyone else was doing it. At least that's my perception. That's what I think, too. The web episodes, putting extended episodes online,
我想说，我觉得NBC.com的人可以说是这方面的开拓者。是的。就像他们在其他人开始做之前，就已经在创作非常酷的、额外的、原创的内容了。至少这是我的看法。我也是这么认为的。网络剧集，把加长版剧集放到网上，
having digital shorts like my adventures with Angela. Yes. So I went digging in my digital clutter, and I found an email that Joy and I had back and forth during this episode where she was coming to set to film me for this segment I would do for NBC.com called Adventures with Angela and I was going to give a holiday behind the scenes tour of the set. Well, Joy couldn't find the video but guess what she shared with me. She said, Angela, I have found someone at NBC that I knew back in the day when she worked there.
制作数字短片，比如我的《安吉拉历险记》。是的。所以我翻找了我那些杂乱的数字文件，我找到了我和乔亚在这一集期间来往的一封邮件，当时她正来到片场拍摄我为NBC.com制作的一个名为《安吉拉历险记》的环节，我将带领大家进行一次布景的节日幕后之旅。嗯，乔亚找不到视频了，但你猜她跟我分享了什么。她说，安吉拉，我在NBC找到了一位当年她在那儿工作时认识的人。
They told me that all of my videos, my adventures with Angela's segments were moved to the archive room and they're on a special server, but her friend there is going to try to get me all of them. I know. I would be so excited to have them. I remember you doing this one for Secret Santa because I remember you giving a tour of all the decorations. And it was really cute.
他们告诉我，我所有的视频，也就是我的《安吉拉历险记》环节都被移到了档案馆，存放在一个特殊的服务器上，但她在那里的一位朋友会设法把它们全部找给我。我知道。能拥有它们我会兴奋极了。我记得你为《秘密圣诞老人》做过这个，因为我记得你带大家参观了所有的装饰。而且真的很可爱。
I remember doing these segments. They were so much fun. And Joya said that there's some more fun digital content coming up. NBC.com was really starting to get in a groove. And she said for season seven, she's gonna have a lot of little nuggets for us. Oh, that is very exciting.
我记得做过这些环节。它们太有趣了。乔亚说还有更多有趣的数字内容即将推出。NBC.com真的开始渐入佳境了。她说到了第七季，她会为我们准备很多小亮点。哦，那太令人兴奋了。
Quick shout out, you guys, to Dundercadia because they list all of these extra scenes. Oh, yes, I saw that. And I'm going to mention a few of them, but there's so many. There's so many. So if you go to Dundercadia or if you have the DVD box set, you can watch this extended producers cut. Fast fact number two is a secret Santa deep dive. Ooh, I'm so excited. I was a lady who Googled four different articles
伙计们，给邓德卡迪亚（Dundercadia）点个赞，因为他们列出了所有这些额外的场景。哦，是的，我看到了。我会提到其中一些，但实在太多了。真的太多了。所以如果你访问邓德卡迪亚或者如果你有DVD套装，你可以观看这个加长制作人剪辑版。趣味事实二是一个关于秘密圣诞老人的深度剖析。哦，我太兴奋了。我是一个谷歌了来自Bustle、维基百科、今日美国和Grunge四篇不同文章的女士。
from Bustle, Wikipedia, USA Today, and Grunge. What do they say? Well, since you know, the secret Santa Gift Exchange is such a big part of this episode, I wanted to know more. And I found out that lots of places have a tradition of exchanging or giving gifts in this secret Santa tradition, but they have different names.
它们都说了什么？嗯，既然你知道，秘密圣诞老人礼物交换是这一集非常重要的一部分，我想了解更多。我发现很多地方都有在秘密圣诞老人传统中交换或赠送礼物的传统，但它们有不同的名字。
I love different names. Me too. I love to see how people celebrate things differently, like around the world. Me too. Well, in the UK, it's called Chris Cringle. In Ireland, it's called Chris Kindle, which is an adaptation of Christ Kindle, which means Christchild. It's not secret Santa there. It'd be secret Chris Cringle. Yeah, but I don't even think you say the secret part. I think you just say, let's a crystal gift exchange. Oh, okay. In Germany, it's called Wichland, which means goblin or else.
我喜欢不同的名字。我也是。我喜欢看世界各地的人们如何以不同的方式庆祝。我也是。嗯，在英国，它叫克里斯·克兰格（Chris Cringle）。在爱尔兰，它叫克里斯·金德尔（Chris Kindle），这是对Christ Kindle的改编，意思是圣婴。在那里它不叫秘密圣诞老人。那会叫秘密克里斯·克兰格。是的，但我觉得你甚至不用说“秘密”那个词。我觉得你只会说，让我们来交换一份水晶礼物吧。哦，好吧。在德国，它叫维奇兰（Wichland），意思是地精或小精灵。
Now, some people believe that the whole thing originated in Scandinavia, where it's called Juke Lop and involves basically leaving a gift at someone's door, knocking and then running away. But in all of these traditions, there's one thing that remains constant, which is that you have to give somebody a gift in secret, either out of the goodness of your heart or through an organized gift exchange, where you like draw names as in our episode. But ultimately, you are not supposed to reveal your identity. So many of these articles pointed to a philanthropist from Lee Summit, Missouri, named Larry Dean Stewart as quote, the original secret Santa, like in America. Oh, okay.
现在，有些人认为这一切起源于斯堪的纳维亚半岛，在那里它被称为Juke Lop，主要是在某人的门前留下礼物，敲门然后逃跑。但在所有这些传统中，有一件事是不变的，那就是你必须秘密地向某人赠送礼物，要么是出于你内心的善良，要么是通过像我们剧集里那样抽签组织的礼物交换。但归根结底，你不应该透露自己的身份。许多这类文章都指出了一位来自密苏里州李斯萨米特的慈善家，名叫拉里·迪恩·斯图尔特（Larry Dean Stewart），被称为“原版秘密圣诞老人”，就像在美国一样。哦，好吧。
The name secret Santa might come from. So the tradition of giving out secret gifts has been going on forever, but this name secret Santa was sort of originally given to this man. Oh, I want to hear all about it. He gave out anonymous gifts during the holidays for more than 25 years. He would walk around wearing sometimes a red sweater. I saw one photo of him in like white overalls with a red sweater and a little red hat. And he would give people $100 bills just randomly. After 9-11, he donated over $25,000 in the form of $100 bills to New Yorkers. He was so famous for handing out this money
“秘密圣诞老人”这个名字可能就由此而来。所以赠送秘密礼物的传统一直都在延续，但“秘密圣诞老人”这个名字最初是给这个人的。哦，我想听听全部的故事。他在节日期间匿名送礼物超过25年。他会穿着一件红色的毛衣四处走动。我看到他的一张照片，穿着白色的工装裤，配着红色的毛衣和一顶小红帽。他会随机给人们100美元的钞票。911事件后，他以100美元钞票的形式向纽约人捐赠了超过25,000美元。他因分发这些钱而如此出名，
that he was profiled in USA today one year, but they kept it anonymous. They didn't say who he was. But his identity was finally revealed in 2006 after he was diagnosed with cancer. It was a pretty aggressive form of cancer, and what I read in an article was that someone knew who he was, and they were going to reveal him, so he decided to come out and say who he was. But according to this article in USA Today, he was quoted as saying he has no strict criteria for who gets the money.
以至于有一年他被《今日美国》报道了，但他们保持了匿名。他们没有说他是谁。但他的真实身份最终在2006年他被诊断出患有癌症后被揭晓。这是一种相当激进的癌症，我在一篇文章中读到的是，有人知道他是谁，并且打算曝光他，所以他决定自己站出来说出他是谁。但根据《今日美国》的这篇文章，据引述，他表示对于谁能得到这笔钱没有严格的标准。
He sometimes worked with local service agencies or he had police officers or firefighters help him identify people who had been devastated by a fire or some other calamity and he sometimes gave those people a thousand dollars or more. But he said most of the money he gave away was handed out to people that he met on the street in diners in laundromats, pawn shops and fast food places. In the article, it also explained how he grew up really struggling and rather poor and
他有时与当地的服务机构合作，或者让警察或消防员帮助他识别那些被火灾或其他灾难摧毁生活的人，他有时会给这些人一千美元或更多。但他说他送出的的大部分钱都是分发给他在街头、餐馆、自助洗衣店、当铺和快餐店遇到的人。文章还解释了他如何在挣扎中长大，相当贫困，
one day he was so hungry that he went to a diner and he ordered a big meal and he couldn't pay for it. And so he pretended like he lost his wallet. And the server came over to him and said, oh, sir, I think you dropped this and it was a $20 bill. Oh, just protected his dignity in that moment. Right. Yeah. And he walked out of the diner.
有一天他饿极了，走进一家餐馆点了一顿大餐，却付不起钱。于是他假装把钱包弄丢了。服务员走到他身边说，哦，先生，我想你把这个落下了，那是一张20美元的钞票。哦，在那个时刻维护了他的尊严。对的。是的。然后他走出了餐馆。
He didn't occur to him what this person had done for him until after he got outside. And then when he made a lot of money, he wanted to go around and give that back. And he actually went back and he found that guy who had given him the $20. The waiter? Yes. And then gave him a bunch of money. And the guy was like, no, you don't have to do that. And he said, well, you started it all. So it is estimated that in his lifetime,
直到走到外面，他才反应过来这个人究竟为他做了什么。后来当他赚了很多钱时，他想回去把钱还给对方。事实上他真的回去找到了那个给他20美元的人。那个服务员？是的。然后给了他一大笔钱。那个人说，不，你不用这么做。他说，嗯，这一切都是你开始的。据估计，在他的一生中，
he gave away $1.3 million. Wow. And there's your original secret Santa. All right, so fast back number three, we found some kittens. The week we were shooting this episode. This is like one of those things guys, it's like is art imitating life or life imitating art because here I had made up the story of finding sprinkles on the parking lot and then years later we found kittens in the parking lot. Yeah, this was the last episode before our big hiatus,
他总共捐出了130万美元。哇。这就是你们的原版秘密圣诞老人。好的，那么趣味事实三，我们发现了小猫。就在我们拍摄这一集的那个星期。这就像是那种事情，伙计们，就像是艺术模仿生活还是生活模仿艺术，因为在这里我编造了一个在停车场发现小不点（Sprinkles）的故事，然后几年后我们在停车场发现了小猫。是的，这是我们漫长假期前的最后一集，
We found kittens in the parking lot. Yeah. This was the last episode before our big hiatus, our costume designer, Alicia, and our property manager, Tom Melby, found two kittens under the costume trailer. Mm-hmm. Little bitty. They were so cute.
我们在停车场发现了小猫。是的。这是我们漫长假期前的最后一集，我们的服装设计师艾丽西亚和我们的物业经理汤姆·梅尔比在服装拖车下发现了两只小猫。嗯。小小的。它们太可爱了。
And Alicia brought them in, and I went in for a wardrobe fitting, and I saw them. Well, at this time, I was working with Kitten Rescue. And so I ended up taking these Kitten's home. Jenna fostered them, tell them their names. Dunder and Mifflin. And Mifflin was a little black and white tuxedo cat
艾丽西亚把它们抱了进来，我去试装时看到了它们。嗯，当时我正在和“拯救小猫”（Kitten Rescue）合作。所以我最终把这些小猫带回家了。珍娜寄养了它们，告诉大家它们的名字。邓德和米夫林。米夫林是一只黑白相间的小燕尾服猫，
and Mifflin was an all black cat. But you know, Mifflin was struggling a little bit. I mean, these were barely weaned kittens and Dunder could eat on his own, but Mifflin was struggling a little bit. I mean, these were barely weaned kittens and Dunder could eat on his own, but Mifflin couldn't. So I gave Mifflin to a volunteer at Kitten Rescue who had experienced bottle feeding, babies. And eventually, they were both adopted together, these little brothers by this young woman named Carrie.
而米夫林是一只全黑的猫。但你知道的，米夫林当时有点吃力。我是说，这些几乎是刚刚断奶的小猫，邓德可以自己吃东西，但米夫林有点吃力。我是说，这些几乎是刚刚断奶的小猫，邓德可以自己吃东西，但米夫林不行。所以我把米夫林送给了一位“拯救小猫”组织的志愿者，她有喂奶瓶婴儿的经验。最终，它们两个小兄弟一起被一个叫卡莉的年轻女性收养了。
And I'm still in touch with her. She still sends me pictures of these guys. It's the sweetest thing. So I reached out to find out how they're doing. She said they are now 12 years old. Wow. She said that Dunder who used to be kind of the more rascally outgoing one has become a little crankier in his old age. He kind of hides when people come over now. Whereas Mithlin, who was always kind of the shy one, loves to get pets from anybody who visits. So, you know, Carrie also ended up being a foster parent for kittens at Kitten Rescue. And she told me that Dunder and Mithlin have helped to foster
我和她至今仍有联系。她仍然会给我发这些家伙的照片。这太甜蜜了。所以我联系她了解它们近况。她说它们现在12岁了。哇。她说邓德过去常常是那种比较调皮外向的猫，但在老了之后脾气变得有点暴躁了。现在有人来家里时他会躲起来。而米夫林一直是个比较害羞的家伙，却喜欢接受任何来访者的抚摸。所以，你知道的，卡莉后来也成了“拯救小猫”组织小猫的寄养家长，她告诉我，在过去的12年里，邓德和米夫林帮助寄养了
uncle, or as she calls it, funcled over 80 kittens in the past 12 years. Wow. And that they're very, very good with all the little kittens that she fosters. It's funny because when I was working with kitten rescue, I think I gave an interview where I said that I had fostered and found homes for over 13 cats, and that got printed as I had 13 cats. In it took me years to get that corrected. It was on like Wikipedia forever, and every time I would do an interview,
叔叔，或者按她的话叫“叔叔职能”（funcled），超过80只小猫。哇。而且它们对她寄养的所有小猫都非常非常好。这很有趣，因为当我还在为“拯救小猫”工作时，我想我接受过一次采访，我说我寄养并为13只以上的猫找到了家，结果被印成了我有13只猫。我花了几年时间才纠正过来。它在维基百科上挂了永远，每次我做采访时，
someone would say, tell me about your 13 cats. I know I feel like, can we please? I fostered 13 cats. And not at the same time, like one by one, right over years. Well, incidentally, Kitten Rescue is where I adopted Sonny, and I'm gonna link to them in our show notes. They are such a great organization, and I also have some really fun photos of Dunder and Mifflin
总有人会说，跟我讲讲你的13只猫吧。我知道，我当时想，我们能别这样吗？我寄养过13只猫。而且不是同时，是一只接一只，多年来积累的。顺便说一句，“拯救小猫”就是我收养桑尼的地方，我会在我们的节目介绍里放上他们的链接。他们真的是一个伟大的组织，而且我还有一些非常有趣的邓德和米夫林的照片，
from when they were Kitten's, as well as now, and we'll put it in our Instagram stories. Oh, I can't wait. You guys, as Jenna was sharing the story, I just was remembering all these memories. And when we would walk on to set, there were these side doors that we would come onto the set of the Dundermifland bullpen from our trailers. We had a wall of like announcements. Like, if someone had a baby, we'd put the photo up there or, you know, just any little thing. I remember when you were in a poker tournament, we put all the thing up there. Just anything that was going on in our lives, casting crew.
从它们还是小猫的时候到现在的都有，我们会把它发到我们的Instagram快拍上。哦，我等不及了。伙计们，当珍娜分享这个故事时，我脑海中不断涌现出所有这些回忆。当我们走进片场时，有两扇侧门，我们可以从拖车直接走到邓德米夫林办公室的布景里。我们有一面墙用来贴各种通知。比如，如果有人生了孩子，我们会把照片贴在那儿，或者，你知道的，任何小事。我记得当你参加扑克锦标赛时，我们把所有东西都贴在那儿了。只要是发生在我们生活中的事，演员和剧组。
And then you would walk by and you would read and you'd be like, oh my gosh, Patrick, you're getting married. That's so great. There'd be little announcements. Well, there was a photo of Dunder and Mifflin. We'd print it off on the rock. A little flyer. Yeah, a little flyer. That hung there.
然后你走过时会读一读，然后会说，哦天哪，帕特里克，你要结婚了。太棒了。会有一些小公告。嗯，那里有一张邓德和米夫林的照片。我们把它打印在纸上了。一个小传单。是的，一个小传单。就挂在那里。
And we would walk past it every day. And we left it up even after they were adopted just like their photo. I love that. I want to see what they look like now. I know. They're so cute. Well, that's all I've got.
我们每天都会从它旁边走过。即使在它们被收养后，我们依然把照片留在那儿，就像它们的照片一样。我真喜欢这样。我想看看它们现在长什么样。我知道。它们太可爱了。好吧，这就是我所有的内容了。
Should we take a break and then come back? And yeah, let's get into this episode. There's so much fun stuff to discuss. This episode kicks off with a very exuberant, merry Christmas from Dwight and Jim, who, if you remember, are now the heads of the party planning committee. Yeah, they're still in charge of the parties. I have to say, they do a good job this year. They do. This is a great Christmas party.
我们要不要休息一下再回来？然后，是的，我们开始聊这一集吧。有太多有趣的事情要讨论了。这一集以德怀特和吉姆充满活力、欢乐的圣诞祝福开场，如果你还记得的话，他们现在是派对策划委员会的负责人。对，他们依然负责派对。我得说，他们今年做得很好。确实很好。这是一个很棒的圣诞派对。
The decor is great. They have some great ideas. Well, I have a reason for that. I'm going to share with you that was in deleted scenes. I can't wait. Well next up Dwight has a talking head where he shares that he put his diabolical plan on hold. I have to share something.
装饰很棒。他们有一些很棒的点子。嗯，我对此有个原因。我要跟你们分享一个被删减镜头里的内容。我等不及了。接下来德怀特有一个独白，他分享说他把他的邪恶计划暂时搁置了。我必须分享一件事。
So when I was talking to Joya about this episode, she said, oh, Angela, I meant to reach out to you about Scott's tauts because we launched a diabolical blog to coincide with Dwight's diabolical plan. What? Yes. It was a weekly blog about Dwight's diabolical Plan. You can still see the blog entries. I'm going to put a link to them in our stories. I'm showing Jenna a picture of what the front page looks like. Oh, it's the coup de Dwight, the Diabolical blog by Dwight K Shrewd.
所以当我跟乔亚聊起这一集时，她说，哦，安吉拉，我本想联系你谈谈“斯科特助学金”（Scott's Tots），因为我们推出了一个邪恶博客来配合德怀特的邪恶计划。什么？是的。这是一个关于德怀特邪恶计划的每周博客。你仍然可以看到这些博客条目。我会在我们的快拍里放一个链接。我正在给珍娜看首页长什么样。哦，那是德怀特政变，由德怀特·K·施鲁特撰写的邪恶博客。
So I'll put that in our stories, but I thought that was so fun. After this Dwight talking head, Jenna, there was a gym talking head that got deleted. It's in the extended producer's cut, but I want to read to you a little bit of it from the shooting draft. Okay, it was actually really sweet. Jim says, lately there have been serious rumors that our company might go bankrupt.
所以我把它放到我们的快拍里，但我觉得这太有趣了。在这个德怀特的独白之后，珍娜，有一个吉姆的独白被删掉了。它在加长制作人剪辑版里，但我从拍摄初稿中读一读其中的一部分。好的，其实非常温馨。吉姆说，最近有严重的传言说我们公司可能会破产。
David Wallace asked me to keep morale high. Then there's B-roll. And the B-roll captures people taking turns rumors that our company might go bankrupt. David Wallace asked me to keep morale high. Then there's B-roll. And the B-roll captures people taking turns going into Jim's office while Jim actually listens and jots down notes. Angela goes in, Kevin Kelly, Stanley, Jim's talking head continues. I asked around what people wanted with Christmas. Get creative, I said. And people weren't really creative exactly. They said, secret Santa, karaoke food, pretty much what we usually have, which is great.
大卫·华莱士要求我保持士气高昂。然后是花絮镜头。花絮镜头捕捉到人们轮流传言公司可能会破产。大卫·华莱士要求我保持士气高昂。然后是花絮镜头。花絮镜头捕捉到人们轮流走进吉姆的办公室，而吉姆则认真倾听并做笔记。安吉拉进去了，凯文、凯利、斯坦利，吉姆的独白继续。我四处打听大家对圣诞节有什么要求。发挥点创意，我说。大家其实并没有那么有创意。他们说，秘密圣诞老人、卡拉OK、食物，基本就是我们通常拥有的那些，这也很棒。
Then there's B-roll of Jim and Dwight, dusting off old decorations. Jim continues to talk. People usually argue about food, so I told everyone to bring their favorites. Then there's B-roll, Angela laying out carrots and celery. Kevin with an enormous chocolate cake, Pam brings in a lasagna, and finally CREED, emptying a large can of beans into a glass-serving bowl. Jim continues,
I made a very organized sign-up sheet for karaoke so there's no fighting. B-Roll of Jim holding up a clipboard next to the karaoke machine with a must take turns written on it in red letters. Kelly Andy and Kevin crowd around to sign up. Jim continues talking. And no crying. Jim hangs up a banner in the conference room. It says Mary Christmas Santa hates tears.
Jim. And then lastly Jim says, I made Phyllis Santa fulfilling a lifelong dream. Phyllis hugs Jim and will not let go. Jim tries to suddenly break free. And then Jim ends this talking head with this. I'm doing a good job I think. Because this year I care. I know it's weird. He shrugs. Happy. That is so sweet! I know, it was a great talking head, and it really showed how Jim was invested in making this a good party. This is good management.
This just reminds me of how Greg Daniels would treat us. He would come around, and he would say, what do you think should happen to your character this year? Yes! And you'd be like, I have ideas! Thank you! We're asking! So now Erin is gonna make an announcement to the bullpen.
She is pleading with whoever is her secret Santa to please stop sending gifts. Her secret Santa is doing a 12 days of Christmas themed gift for her. And she says that her cat killed the turtle dove, the French hens are making a nest in her hair. She has scratches down her face. She's having a hard time with this gift. Oh my gosh, she seems really miserable. Well, I wanted to share with you guys that the DVD commentary for this episode is Ellie
Kimber, Mindy Kaling and Claire Scanlon. Oh, great. Yeah. And they talked a little bit about this scratch on Ellie's face. Mindy shared that they had a test model that they did a few different types of scratches on and took pictures of and then Mindy had to pick which scratch she liked. Yes. Randy said our makeup artist Laverern created the effects of the scratch.
I guess Randall and Paul both were really pleased with the first try and that's the one they picked. He said LeVern's team was masterful at executing this gag. Well, we had a fan catch during this scene at reception from Ursula N in Toledo, Ohio who says at two minutes and 33 seconds, there is a card on Aaron's desk. Is that card the one where Michael photoshopped himself into Carol's family ski trip back in season three because it looks just like it?
I assumed it on it. It absolutely looks like it. I think it is. I think Michael is still setting that card out. That is brilliant and perfect. I also caught a card taped to the front of reception, and it was a Christmas card that me and Brian and Oscar made and gave to everyone. Oh my gosh. I remember you guys used to do an accountants card at Christmas. Yes, it would make them take a picture with me and character, and we would give it to everyone. Well, Andy has a talking head where he begged Whitenjim to give him Aaron for secret Santa and he's the one who's giving out the 12 days of Christmas gifts and he says is it his fault that the first eight days amount to 30 birds and during this talking head you can see him trying to put
little bow ties on some swans. You see Aaron go to her car and it's filled with geese. I asked Randy Cortre, how did we pull off these shots with the geese and the swans? He said once again, we use Bob Dunn's animal rentals in Silmar, California. We needed seven swans in the lobby, and they required three days of prep and rehearsal. He said swans can be very aggressive toward people that they don't know. Oh, yeah. So the extra days of prep were to just let them walk around
this lobby area and meet Ed Helms. And lady, I remember one day at lunch, Ed was eating like really fast. And he said he had to finish eating quickly because he had to go spend time with the swans. Oh my gosh, I don't doubt it. They had to get to know him. I was once chased by a very aggressive duck. In Indonesia, they would use ducks and stuff to protect like a guard duck. Yeah, like a guard duck. And I was on a walk. It was up in the mountains. And I was like probably like 11 in this duck.
Like chase me. I was terrified. I was like, oh my god. They're scary. Yeah. I mean, they'll come for you. They'll come for you. Well, the six geese that were in Aaron's car also had to do three days of prep. We had three trainers each day to wrangle all the birds. They created a fenced-in area in our warehouse. That's where they would stay. It was very cool and dark, I guess they like that. Randy said that the total cost for the four days of birds and trainers was $9,603. Now we also got a fan question from Liam D. in Ireland
who said, he loves the storyline where Andy gives Aaron the 12 Days of Christmas. And he said, did you know that in 1982, there was a record by an Irish actor and comedian named Frank Kelly called Christmas Countdown, where he recalls all of the gifts in the 12 Days of Christmas song. It's basically the same idea. Someone is sending them gifts for the 12 days of Christmas song, it's basically the same idea.
Someone is sending them gifts for the 12 days of Christmas. It ends up just as bad for him as it did for Aaron. He said this song was a chart hit in Ireland, Australia, and the UK. I have an audio clip. Ooh, I want to hear it. Day 7. Nula, we are not enused by your little joke. Seven swans are swimming as a most romantic idea, Who I want to hear it? and I will smell as bad as the living room can, but please lay off. It is not fair. Okay, so he's so right though, when he said they've gone completely savage. I know. So it's just very funny. He's just earnestly writing these letters to Nora to like, please stop after every gift.
They did enjoy the five golden rings. He was like, okay, that was a nice touch. But otherwise, the birds are destroying this house. That's so fun. I want to hear the whole thing. Well, maybe we can put a link. I found it on YouTube. We'll put it in stories. Yeah. Now we have maybe one of the sweetest Phyllis talking heads. She's in full Santa outfit and she tears up. She says it's been a long journey, but she's finally Santa Claus. I was so moved by this.
I know. This is Phyllis at her best. She does this thing where she's so deeply and realistically commits. And Ernest from the heart. Yes. And it just becomes something deeper than comedic. I love it.
And then right after, Creed's like, what if you've been really bad, like bordering on evil? Like, yeah, what happened, Santa? Well, we also get a little peek into Dwight's secret Santa gift. Someone has been sending him different pieces of a machine and he has been trying to put them together. This is so perfect for Dwight. Like talk about someone knowing Dwight and like giving him the perfect gift. Yes. Well, we get to see Pam with her famous lasagna which is, you know, she just makes it from the box, Jenna. I know. I mean, people ask her, where did she get this recipe?
It's from the box. She is just prattling on and Oscar is not paying attention. He's looking out the window. At warehouse, fella. Throw on the football. Mm-hmm. Pam clocks this and this is going to start her into matchmaker mode.
Mm-hmm. I wanted to share two things about this scene, Angela. Number one, I can make lasagna from memory. So can I? And my family uses cottage cheese instead of ricotta cheese. It is, I don't know, maybe a Missouri thing. It's definitely a my family thing. It's so good. It's a milder cheese, especially for kids. You know? I can layer it up. This was one of my three big meals that I learned how to make before I went off to college.
We must have been in the same sort of mindset, because I was like, oh, Lasagna, I can eat off that for days. I'll learn how to make it. Anytime I had anyone over for dinner, Lasagna. Lasagna. Yeah.
The other thing I want to share is that I am wearing belly bump D. Oh. over for dinner. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas.
Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas.
Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. Las Vegas. But here's the thing. According to the belly tracker, the banker, which is our next episode, was actually shot before Scott's tots. Do you go down a size? I think I do, because according to the tracker,
the banker is belly C. So let's see next week, my belly might get smaller for a second. Well, Michael is gonna arrive to address to Santa. And Pam says we already have a Santa. Michael is so upset that Jim let Phyllis take over a Santa. Yeah, he says a woman. Where does it stop?
He says, he can't believe it, but Jim will not budge. And then Michael says, you have to tell her she can't be Santa. Jim's like, I won't do that. He says, just do it anonymously. You can send her like a note, like ransom style. With letters cut out, I have some in my drawer. How many ransom notes is he sending to people? Well, you know, nowadays, you can just download a font for your computer. Ransom note font style. Yeah, Michael, you don't have to go
cut all the letters out and put them in your drawer. But we know he's not using his computer much. We've established that. No, it's just a place to put post-its. Well, Jenna, this starts a whole segment. I'm calling the dueling Santas. One of the best segments of all time. Of all time. Phyllis has a Santa photo op.
Again, amazing setup by Jim and Dwight. I know. She's got the chair and the backdrop, the whole thing. Everyone is going to take their picture with Santa. Well, Michael's ticked off. He wants his own Santa photo up. Mm-hmm. Yeah, so he's gonna set himself up in a chair
right there across from reception. Yeah. He wants to sit on his lap. Someone comes sit on his lap. Well, I guess the first person to sit on Michael's lap is gonna be Kevin. He's so excited. Kevin says he's never been able to do this before.
Yeah. So Kevin sits on Michael's lap. Michael's like, oh, what would you like for Christmas little boy? And Kevin's like, I don't know. I didn't know you were gonna ask me that. And Michael's like, what did you think was going to happen? And Kevin's like, I didn't know.
No one's ever let me sit on their lap before. Michael's really struggling now. He's like, just tell me what toys you want. And Kevin's taken a long time to think about it. Clearly Michael is uncomfortable. Yes. I found a quote from an entertainment weekly article from Mindy, where she says, quote, when Kevin unburdened himself on Michael's lap, Steve's voice changed to this distressed guttural mumble
showing the instantaneous agony he was in. This was literally a laugh out loud moment because you can see me laughing in the background completely breaking character. And then we got a fan question from Robbie V. in South Korea who said, at 7 minutes 56 seconds, if you pause, you can clearly see Ed Helms and Mindy Kaelin breaking so hard. A few seconds later, BJ Novak started to break. They were all laughing so hard Ed needed to hide
from the camera. Will you guys please share your stories about this scene, Jenna and Angela, were you also laughing during this scene? Oh my gosh. Oh, Robbie. Robbie, I would say overwhelmingly, this was one time where the entire cast broke. The entire cast. I've read so many interviews in prepping for this episode where John, Ed and Brian all talk about how they were all breaking. I read where Veda, our script supervisor supervisor said how she would have to mark whenever someone laughed in a take and it was like everyone. They didn't have any footage of us not laughing. None of it.
They didn't have any. We never got it. That's why all the footage shows us breaking the background. That's exactly right. On the commentary, Claire Scanlon, who who was our editor talked about how difficult it was to edit the scene because someone was constantly laughing. And if you watch you guys all see Mindy break, Ed literally had to go behind the wall. Yeah. There was like a plant and a wall and you watch him go and hide. There are a lot of bloopers from this.
You guys, I just felt like we had to hear them. Oh my gosh This is gonna take me back. I can sit on your lap. You can sit on my lap all you want because I am a male Santa And that is something that Phyllis cannot do. Oh my god. Okay. It's really comfortable Tell me what you want little boy. Oh It's really comfortable. Okay. Tell me what you want, little boy. Oh, I don't know. I didn't know you were gonna ask me that.
What did you think was going to happen? I didn't know. No one's ever let me sit on their lap before. Hurry up, just say some toys. Mm-hmm. Okay. Can you give me some choices? Oh my God, Kevin, please.
Oh, sorry. Oh, sorry. Oh, God, Kevin, please. Sorry. I'm sorry. Oh, my God. John dives out of frame like we're all losing it. You notice in those scenes there are no like cutaways to the reverse. There are no reaction shots. No, they couldn't. There were the people who were like stationed behind this action and they had to try to hold
it together. The rest of us. We were all there, we're all watching. You don't see us because we couldn't ever act. No, we were just all laughing. That like took me back watching it and reading everyone's like stories from that day. It was so much fun. Well, Phyllis is mad. She demands that Jim take care of this double-sand to
situation. Otherwise, she's going to have to get Bob involved. Yeah. And Jim is like, what? And then she goes, never mind, I shouldn't have said that. Oh my God. That is Bob up to. I don't know. Aaron is going to jokingly ask Andy if he's her secret Santa. And he jokingly admits that he is. Yeah. This is very similar to what happened in murder. Right. Where they're jokingly asking each other on a date.
This is a downfall of their relationship. Where they don't just come out. No one's just thinking straight up. Right. I don't know if you notice, but at seven minutes, 15 seconds, the golf picture is still on the wall. I did notice.
I'll have you know, the week that we shot Secret Santa is the same week that Mafia aired. So now that Mafia has aired, we have 100% committed to cutting out the storyline where Aaron destroys the watercolor. I'm telling you, that is how last minute that decision was, how long that fight was. Could you imagine if the show ended and it was just a golf picture there? I cannot. And we just walk out and the last shot is a golf picture. No.
No. Tragedy. Tragedy. Hoping a frame. Hoping a frame, people. Well, Oscar's gonna go down to the warehouse to hand out everyone's paychecks. There was a really fun scene in the shooting draft that didn't make it in where Oscar goes to Angela. She's about to go hand out the paychecks. That's who hands them out. I remember that. Yeah, and Oscar's like, wait, wait, wait, Angela, you know what? I'll go hand him out. And she's like, why? And he's like, oh, and it's like Oscar knows her so well. He's like, it's cold down there.
And he's like, he lists all these things. And she's like, okay, fine. And let's him go hand out the checks. But he's looking for Matt. But Matt's not there. He's out on a delivery. And Darrell's like, I'll take it. I'll give it to him. And Oscars like, no, no, I can wait.
Yeah. Darryl's on to him. Oh yeah. Have you ever done something like this? Of course, we all have. I remember when I was younger, like a kid. I had a little bit of a crush on one of the boys in my neighborhood. And I used to look out the window. And when I would see him outside like playing soccer or something, I would conveniently need to go to the mailbox. Yeah, hoping hoping that he would like wave at me or something that we could have a run in.
It never happened. I mean, in college, I watched bassmasters, because the guy I liked was really into watching bassmasters, watching people fish and talk about the hooks they used and the lures and the whatnot. These are the things you do. Yeah, when you have a crush. Yeah, when all of a sudden this guy is like,
I think on Sunday I'm gonna watch bassmasters. I'm like, oh yeah, it's so great. That guy, the host, he's hilarious. And then you're like, who is the host? There is no host of fast masters. What is fast masters? And you couldn't Google back then because it was just invented.
I know. Yeah, it wasn't invented yet. There was no internet. I will never let that one go. I know it's too fun. Clearly, it's too fun. It's one of my favorite bits now. Well, Michael is still sitting in the chair upstairs upstairs trying to get people to sit on his lap.
He is now like wrestling Ryan onto his lap while saying, I need this, I need this. Claire and Mindy also talked in the commentary that when Jim steps in and is like, hey, you know, Michael, you can't, you know, you can't grab someone in the office and say, I need this while forcing them onto your lap. Yeah. It makes me laugh out loud every time John's delivery is so. They shared on the commentary that he kept laughing and so many takes. That's the thing. Like when you know something is funny, even though you have to deliver it, it like it tickles you while you're doing.
Yes. funny even though you have to deliver it. It like it tickles you while you're doing it. Yes! This scene is going to end with Michael putting his Santa hat into the punch bowl and storming out. So rude. Mindy talked about something in the commentary. I thought it was really interesting. She said at eight minutes thirty-nine seconds when Michael makes his big announcement that he wants a vote on who is the true Santa. Mindy said, and I'm quoting her, one of the great legacies of the show is the announcements outside of Michael's office. She goes on to say, I used to call it, Act Break Alley. The writers would have Michael come out of his office, make an announcement, and that
funny even though you have to deliver it. It like it tickles you while you're doing it. Yes! This scene is going to end with Michael putting his Santa hat into the punch bowl and storming out. So rude. Mindy talked about something in the commentary. I thought it was really interesting. She said at eight minutes thirty-nine seconds when Michael makes his big announcement that he wants a vote on who is the true Santa. Mindy said, and I'm quoting her, one of the great legacies of the show is the announcements outside of Michael's office. She goes on to say, I used to call it, Act Break Alley. The writers would have Michael come out of his office, make an announcement, and that
would often lead to the Act Break. And that's exactly what happens here. It's true. So you got a little act break out of the way there. Dwight is convinced that his secret Santa is sending him pieces of a gun. But this last piece doesn't make any sense. Why did they send him a dial?
They should have sent him a trigger. And Meredith and Silicitor like, why do you think it's a gun? And then Stanley has a great line where he says, unless the missing piece is a gun, you don't have a gun. I don't know why that tickles me so much. His delivery was so good. We got a fan question from Beth G.
in Olympia Washington, who came up with the list of Dwight's speculations on what his Christmas present might be as he builds it. You know, he has that piece of paper with the list. And Beth said, I never noticed that Speculum was on the list, but during a recent rewatch I noticed an almost dyed laughing. So I found a list of all the things that Dwight thinks. This is what's on his piece of paper.
Okay. And answer to your question, Beth, this would be the writers. The writers would have come up with this list. Phil Shay would have gone to the writers and said, what do you want me to write on this piece of paper for Dwight? Right. And he would have had to write this list over and over and over and over again on various pads of paper because every take
好的。回答你的问题，贝丝，这应该是编剧们想出来的。编剧们会想出这个清单。菲尔·谢伊会去找编剧，问他们想让我在这张纸上为德怀特写些什么。对吧。他必须在一叠叠的纸上一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地写下这个清单，因为每一个镜头
rain was going to scratch one out. So here was the list of things that Dwight thought this might be. An art vark trap, beaver trap, gun, chipmunk trap, possum trap, skunk trap, lobster trap, man trap, lathe, abdomenizer, speculum. He was mostly convinced it was some sort of trap in the animal trap. Santa Phyllis is now going to do the tree lighting reveal and it's so festive and cheery.
雷恩都要划掉一个。所以这就是德怀特认为这可能是的东西的清单。食蚁兽陷阱、海狸陷阱、枪、花栗鼠陷阱、负鼠陷阱、臭鼬陷阱、龙虾陷阱、人陷阱、车床、腹肌塑造器、窥器。他基本确信某种捕兽器就是动物陷阱。菲利斯圣诞老人现在要做点亮圣诞树的环节了，这真是喜庆又欢快。
I love Phyllis in the scene. I know. I absolutely love it. Michael is starting to get real sour. Oh yeah. So he has this talking head, where he says, I don't need a lot for Christmas, like diamonds or broach pendants. He just wants to be Santa. And this whole time, he is like reversing his Santa costume. Taking this decorative Christmas robe off his credenza,
我很喜欢这一幕里的菲利斯。我知道。我真的超级喜欢。迈克尔开始变得很不爽。哦，对。所以他有一个单人镜头，在镜头里他说，我对圣诞节没有太多要求，比如钻石或胸针吊坠。他只想当圣诞老.子。而在整个过程中，他就像是在反向穿戴他的圣诞老人服装。把这件装饰性的圣诞长袍从他的矮书柜上拿下来，
making it into a belt, I wanna give a shout out to Steve Skills right here. I put it in my document, I need everyone to appreciate how hard this is to do. Yes, I wrote it too, I put two little stars by it, I said go to nine minutes, 52 seconds. Michael goes from Santa to Jesus, and Steve had to do all the dialogue,
把它做成一条腰带，我要在这里向史蒂夫·斯基尔斯（Steve Carell）致敬。我把它写在我的文档里了，我需要每个人都意识到这件事有多难做到。对，我也写了，我在旁边画了两颗小星，我说快进到9分52秒。迈克尔从圣诞老人变成了耶稣，而史蒂夫必须把所有的台词一口气说完，
changes outfit, put the belts on in one shot. There are no cutaways. This is truly amazing. I cannot express to you how hard it is to do even ordinary business while you're acting. How many times would I have to do a scene where I'm supposed to walk in with a bag of groceries, set it down and take some items out of the bag.
换好衣服，系上腰带，一气呵成。中间没有任何镜头切换。这简直太惊人了。我无法向你们表达，在演戏的同时还要做日常琐事有多难。我有多少次必须去演这样一场戏：我本该拎着一袋杂货走进来，把它放下，然后从袋子里拿几样东西出来。
Suddenly, I am incapable of doing that action. I multitask in my kitchen constantly, and I'm always thinking about it too, like as I'm like shutting the fridge with my foot while scrambling an egg and drinking coffee and like organizing some homework papers in the morning and holding a conversation. I think to myself, if this was written out for me,
突然之间，我连这个动作都不会做了。我经常在厨房里一心多用，而且我总是一边做一边脑子里想着别的事，比如我一边用脚关上冰箱门，一边炒鸡蛋、喝咖啡，还要在早晨整理一些家庭作业的纸张，同时和人聊天。我心里想，如果这一幕是被写进剧本让我来演，
I could never do it. I don't know what it is. It's so hard just to memorize your lines and say them truthfully. This amount of business is people should study it. He does such a good job. And with comic timing! I know.
我绝对做不到。我也不知道为什么。光是记住台词并真诚地把它们说出来就已经够难了。这种肢体动作的量，人们真该好好研究一下。他演得太棒了。而且还带有喜剧节奏！我知道。
I always think of this when I would watch shows like E.R. or Grey's Anatomy, when they have the gurney flying through the hallway and they're yelling out all of this when I would watch shows like ER or Grace Anatomy, when they have the gurney flying through the hallway and they're yelling out all of this medical jargon like, stay give me this guy some of that! And they're like having to do all this action. I'm like, well, that'll be a job I never have.
每当我看到像《急诊室的故事》或《实习医生格蕾》这样的剧时，我总是会想到这一点，当急救推车飞驰穿过走廊，他们大喊着所有这些医疗术语，比如，快给我给这个人来点这个！他们还得做一堆动作。我就想，好吧，这绝对是我永远不会去干的工作。
Because, yes, that's a lot of talking and moving at the same time. Yeah, I won't be able to do it. Lots of business is hard to do. Lots of business. Because then also you have to like match it. Yeah, every time. We were both very impressed. We were, we were also cast on the perfect show because we often didn't have to do a lot of business. We were just at our desk. True. Michael returns to the bullpen now. He's Jesus Christ. Angela applaud.
因为，没错，那需要在说话的同时做大量的移动。对，我可做不来。有大量肢体动作的戏很难演。大量的动作。因为接着你还得把动作对上。对，每一次都要对上。我们俩都印象深刻。真的，而且我们参演的也是一部完美的剧，因为我们通常不需要做太多动作。我们只是坐在办公桌前。确实。迈克尔现在回到了大办公室。他成了耶稣基督。安吉拉鼓掌。
She's the only one applauding. I mean, finally, as far as she's concerned. Right, finally, we have a real Christmas party. I went to the script to see if me applauding was written in the script. It was. It says Angela claps. Well, lady, I think we should take a break,
她是唯一一个在鼓掌的人。我是说，对她而言，总算盼到了。没错，总算迎来了一个真正的圣诞派对。我去查了剧本，看看我鼓掌是不是剧本里写好的。还真是。上面写着安吉拉鼓掌。好吧，女士们，我觉得我们该休息一下了，
but before we do, I just want to quickly bring up this moment in the break room where Andy has asked Phyllis, please do not tell Aaron, I'm her secret Santa. And she says, okay, I won't. I'll say it's Michael. Andy's like great. What if Phyllis can throw Michael under the bus? She's like, I'm going for it.
但在我们休息之前，我只想快速提一下休息室里的这个瞬间，安迪曾请求菲利斯，请千万别告诉艾琳我是她的秘密圣诞老人。然后她说，好的，我不会说的。我会说是迈克尔。安迪听了觉得太棒了。要是菲利斯能把迈克尔推出来背锅呢？她心想，我豁出去了。
Well, listen, he deserves it. I know. I know. I know. I know. All right, we'll take a break and be right back. [♪ INTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ [♪ INTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ We are back, Kelly and Erin are singing some Christmas carols. I want you guys to know there was a whole lot more singing that got cut out.
好吧，听着，他罪有应得。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。好了，我们休息一下，马上回来。[♪ 片头音乐播放中 [♪ [♪ 片头音乐播放中 [♪ 我们回来了，凯莉和艾琳在唱着圣诞颂歌。我想让你们知道，其实还有一大堆歌唱镜头被剪掉了。
Really? Oh yeah. And while they're singing, Pam is going to ask Oscar if he's talked to Matt. And then she is going into full matchmaker mode. And she's just gonna talk up Oscar's pete. How many times do I say pete? You're so awkward, it's so cringey. Pam is just so delighted to be a matchmaker.
真的吗？哦，是的。在她们唱歌的同时，帕姆去问奥斯卡有没有跟马特聊过。然后她就开启了全方位的红娘模式。她开始疯狂夸奖奥斯卡。我说了多少次“夸奖”？你好尴尬，太让人脚趾抠地了。帕姆只是太热衷于当红娘了。
I know it was really fun to play. We had a fan question from Robby V in South Korea who played Matt from the warehouse. Guys, Matt was played by Sam Daley. In addition to the office, Sam has appeared on such shows as The Magicians and CIS, Heart of Dixie, and in recurring roles on Madame Secretary and The Undercovers and most recently on Bull,
我知道，演这一段真的很有趣。我们收到了来自韩国的罗比·V的粉丝提问，他饰演的是仓库里的马特。伙计们，马特是由萨姆·戴利饰演的。除了《办公室》，萨姆还出演过《魔法师》、《CSI》、《迪克西的心》等剧，并在《国务卿夫人》和《卧底情侣》中担任常驻角色，最近还出演了《法外之王》，
he is also the son of actor Tim Daly. Oh my God, I was so excited when he was on set because I loved wings. Loved wings. I watched every episode. I even went to a taping, you guys. You did? Yes, I came out to LA to visit like years before I lived here and I went to a taping, you guys. You did? Yes, I came out to LA to visit years before I lived here,
他也是演员蒂姆·戴利的儿子。哦天哪，他在片场的时候我超级激动，因为我太喜欢《御风男儿》了。超喜欢《御风男儿》。我看过每一集。我甚至还去现场看过录制呢，伙计们。真的吗？是的，我在来这里住之前的很多年前来洛杉矶玩过，我还去现场看过录制，伙计们。真的吗？是的，我在来这里住之前的很多年前来洛杉矶玩过，
and I went to a taping of wings. I did that same thing, too. I came out, it was like a special workshop for people who were interested in the biz. It was through UCLA, I think, because we stayed on the campus, and they took us all around, and one of the things we got to do was go to a live television taping. I was fascinated.
我去看了《御风男儿》的录制。我也做过同样的事。我当时来过，那就像是一个专门为对这行感兴趣的人举办的特别研讨会。我想是通过加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）办的，因为我们住在校园里，他们带着我们四处参观，我们能做的事情之一就是去观看电视节目录制。我当时太着迷了。
I loved it. I was coming out to visit my friend's brother was going to college here. And we came and visited him and he took us to a live taping. Crystal Bernard during an act break, you know, because it was like a four camera show where you're in an audience.
我太喜欢了。我当时是来找我朋友的哥哥的，他当时在这里上大学。我们来探望他，他带我们去看了现场录制。克里斯托夫·伯纳德在节目中场休息的时候，你们知道的，因为那是一个有现场观众的四机位情景喜剧，
And they would have like breaks. She came up with her guitar and sang a whole song and she was such a good singer. That is so sweet. You know that's a nice cast. Yeah. When I did my taping of that 70 show, the entire cast after the show was over went out to the audience and signed autographs and it mean this was like year like six or something, I was so impressed. Well, we were very excited to have Sam on set. We were Sam did an interview with bleepamag.com. Angela, thank you for forwarding me this. They asked him if he gets recognized for being Matt on our show. And he said, yes, nine times out of 10, if he gets recognized,
他们会有休息时间。她带着吉他走出来，唱了一整首歌，而且她歌唱得真好听。太甜了。你们知道那是一个很好的剧组。是的。当我录制《那七十年代秀》的时候，整个剧组在演出结束后都走到观众席给观众签名，而且这已经是第六季左右了，我当时印象极其深刻。好吧，萨姆能来片场我们真的很兴奋。我们，萨姆接受了bleepamag.com的采访。安吉拉，谢谢你把这个转发给我。他们问他是否因为在我们剧里演了马特而被认出来。他说，是的，十次里有九次如果他被认出来，
it's for having been on the office. He also said, quote, it was the first show I'd seen every episode of when I went to work on it. I knew where to go in the office and who sat where and everything. It was such an incredible experience. It was supposed to be a tiny role, but it turned into a recurring guest spot for a few episodes. I'll never take that for granted and being around all those other actors was a blessing. Sam, you were a blessing.
都是因为出演过《办公室》。他还说，原话是：“这是我参演之前就看过每一集的头一部剧。我知道办公室里该去哪，谁坐在哪，以及一切。这真的是一段不可思议的经历。这本该是个小角色，但最后却变成了几集常驻客串。我永远不会把这当成理所当然，能和所有这些优秀的演员在一起是一种福气。”萨姆，你才是我们的福气。
You were so delightful. And he is gonna be in two more episodes. We just really liked him so much. Well, Jen, I have two things to share about this scene. So we see Matt from the warehouse upstairs. Did you notice the other warehouse workers? Yes, I noticed, Matt, and all the guys are at this party.
你太可爱了。而且他还要在另外两集里出现。我们真的很喜欢他。好吧，詹，关于这场戏我有两件事要分享。我们看到楼上的仓库里有马特。你注意到其他仓库工人了吗？是的，我注意到了，马特和所有这些家伙都在这个派对上。
Well, there was a whole runner that was cut from the episode. It is in the extended producer's cut where Michael goes down to the warehouse and invites all of them up to the party. It does not go over well. Why? Jim is annoyed because he did not plan to feed that many people. Oh! writes all of them up to the party. It does not go over well. Why? Jim is annoyed because he did not plan to feed that many people.
其实有一个完整的支线剧情被从这集里剪掉了。它在加长制作人剪辑版里，迈克尔下到仓库，邀请他们所有人都上来参加派对。结果效果并不好。为什么？吉姆很恼火，因为他根本没打算喂饱那么多人。哦！邀请他们所有人都上来参加派对。结果效果并不好。为什么？吉姆很恼火，因为他根本没打算喂饱那么多人。
Oh. I thought it was really cute because he was all of a sudden concerned about food. The rest of the office is grumpy because the warehouse workers start eating everything kind of take over. Angela has a talking head where she says, she can hardly pretend to like the people
哦。我觉得这真的太可爱了，因为他突然开始担心食物不够。办公室里剩下的人都觉得很不爽，因为仓库工人们开始狼吞虎咽地吃所有东西，甚至有点喧宾夺主了。安吉拉有一个单人镜头，她说，她甚至很难假装喜欢
in the actual office. Let alone all the extra people now. There is a scene in the conference room where we learn that match has a nickname, Garfield. Oh, because she loves lasagna. Because she loves lasagna. And when she sees it, she has to eat it all. This results in a scene where she eats the entire lasagna that Pam brought while the warehouse guys are chaining
真正办公室里的人。更不用说现在这些额外的人了。会议室里有一场戏，我们得知马特有个外号叫“加菲猫”。哦，因为她太爱吃千层面了。因为她太爱吃千层面了。当她看到千层面时，她必须把它全部吃光。这就导致了一场戏：帕姆带来的整盘千层面都被她一个人吃光了，而仓库的家伙们在一边齐声高喊着
Garfield, Garfield, Garfield. Amazing. Yes, there were so many extra scenes of the warehouse people driving everyone in the bullpen crazy. The second thing I want to share is on the commentary, Mindy and Ellie talked about how when they met Sam Daly, who played Matt, they got so tickled because they thought Sam and Ellie talked about how when they met Sam daily, who played Matt, they got so tickled because they thought Sam and Ellie looked a lot alike in
加菲猫，加菲猫，加菲猫。太棒了。是的，有太多关于仓库员工把大办公室里每个人都快逼疯的额外镜头了。我想分享的第二件事是，在评论音轨中，明迪和艾莉谈到，当她们遇到饰演马特的萨姆·戴利时，她们觉得太逗了，因为她们觉得萨姆和艾莉在
real life. Like they could be brother and sister? Yes! So I did a side-by-side and I want to show you. All right Jenna, look at this. I'll put it in stories. I see it. Oh my gosh! They definitely could be family. I know. So I guess this is something Ellie was tickled about, Ellie and Mindy during the week of filming. Michael is very cranky. He has like sat down kind of in the very middle of the party
现实生活中长得非常像。就像他们可能是失散的兄妹或姐弟？没错！所以我做了一张对比图，我想给你们看一看。好吧，詹娜，看看这个。我会把它发到快拍里。我看到了。哦天哪！他们绝对可以是一家人。我知道。所以我想这是艾莉觉得很好笑的一点，艾莉和明迪在拍摄的那周一直这么觉得。迈克尔非常暴躁。他差不多坐在派对的正中间，
with a microphone and he is narrating the gifts that are being handed out. Yeah, he's doing like snarky commentary. Yeah. Angela gets some fabric. Some gray fabric. She is so touched. I know. This person really knew her well.
手里拿着一个话筒，正在对正在分发的礼物进行实况解说。对，他在进行尖酸刻薄的评论。对。安吉拉拿到了一些布料。一些灰色的布料。她感动得不行。我知道。这个人真的很了解她。
Michael says now she can make another dress that goes past her well. Michael says now she can make another dress that goes past her feet. It is also during this snarky commentary that Michael reveals that Andy is Aaron's secret Santa. Oof. Oh man, Aaron does not look happy. Michael continues to spiral, So he calls David Wallace and he has one of my favorite lines. He says a woman has you slurped his role as Santa. That's right. He also says, guess who I'm dressed as? And I love David Wallace's response because he says, either you tell me or I'm hanging up. I'm not guessing what you're doing. Well, David said this is a really bad time and asked for Stephanie his assistant to step off. Yes. And then Aaron also needs to get off the phone.
迈克尔说现在她可以再做一件垂到脚面的裙子了。迈克尔说现在她可以再做一件垂到脚面的裙子了。也正是在这段尖酸刻薄的解说期间，迈克尔透露安迪是艾琳的秘密圣诞老人。哎呦。哦天哪，艾琳看起来一点都不高兴。迈克尔的状态继续急转直下，于是他给大卫·华莱士打电话，说出了我最喜欢的台词之一。他说一个女人抢走了他圣诞老人的角色。没错。他还说，猜猜我打扮成什么样？我特别喜欢大卫·华莱士的回答，因为他说，要么你告诉我，要么我就挂电话了。我才不猜你在搞什么鬼。好吧，大卫说现在真不是时候，并让他的助理斯蒂芬妮先出去。是的。然后艾琳也需要挂电话。
Michael's like have they always been here? David tells Michael that the company has a buyer and he and Alan are out of work like just you know what everyone's gonna be gone. Everyone. Michael hears that. Oh my gosh. He said you know what earlier today the office needed Santa. Then they needed another Santa. Then they needed Jesus. And now they need Michael. And that's one suit fill us can't fit into. At 14 minutes 38 seconds, I'd like to point out a snow alert. There is now, do we have a snow alert? We have a snow alert.
迈克尔一副“他们一直都在这儿吗？”的样子。大卫告诉迈克尔公司已经找到了买家，他和阿兰都失业了——就好像，你知道的，所有人都要卷铺盖走人了。所有人。迈克尔听到这个消息。哦天哪。他说，你知道吗，今天早些时候，办公室需要圣诞老人。然后他们需要另一个圣诞老人。接着他们需要耶稣。现在他们需要迈克尔。而这正是菲利斯塞不进去的一套制服。在14分38秒处，我想指出一个降雪警报。现在正有，我们有降雪警报吗？我们有降雪警报。
There is some snow falling gently behind Michael out his window. It's evening now and it's begun snowing. This will be important later. It's evening now and it's begun snowing. This will be important later. Well, the way you solve any crisis is you buy pizza, lots of it. Michael's gonna send white with his password. You know, you have fun at the, uh, uh, uh, uh.
迈克尔窗外的身后正有雪花轻轻飘落。现在已经是傍晚了，而且开始下雪了。这在后面会很重要。现在已经是傍晚了，而且开始下雪了。这在后面会很重要。好吧，应对任何危机的办法就是买披萨，买一大堆。迈克尔要用他的密码派怀特去买。你知道的，你在……呃……呃……呃……玩得开心。
Yeah, so his pin is 9622. That is why I'm CA. The candy bag had some really fun alternates for what Michael's pin number might be. Oh yeah. Here's the first one. I don't wanna say it, but it's the year everyone was scared by Y2K.
对，所以他的密码是9622。这就是为什么我是青年会（YMCA）。糖果袋里有一些非常有趣的备选方案，关于迈克尔的密码可能是什么。哦，是的。这是第一个。我不想说，但那是每个人都被千年虫吓坏了的年份。
Here's another one. I don't want to say it, but it's the year we partied like it's 1999. Here's another one. I don't want to say it, but it's the first line in a famous song about the alphabet. And then this was my favorite. When Dwight says what is your pin, Michael was going to say, 938562087116689473. I was just going to be like this ridiculously long number. Those were all of our candy bag must shoot alternates for this. And we stayed with the shooting drafts, scripted YMCA. Aaron's gonna ask Andy, what was he thinking, giving her all of those gifts?
这是另一个。我不想说，但那是我们狂欢得像是在过1999年的年份。这是另一个。我不想说，但这是一首关于字母表的著名歌曲里的第一句歌词。然后这是我最喜欢的一个。当德怀特问密码是什么时，迈克尔本来要说：938562087116689473。我本来打算说一个这种长得离谱的数字。这些都是我们为这场戏拍摄糖果袋时必须拍的备选方案。而我们最后保留了拍摄初稿里剧本写定的YMCA。艾琳要去问安迪，他到底在想什么，为什么要送给她所有这些礼物？
But you know what, Andy's not gonna give up. He's not gonna throw in the towel. Not gonna happen. He's not. Mm-hmm. And later on, I'm glad he didn't. Michael addresses the group. He's got the pizza.
但你知道吗，安迪是不会放弃的。他才不会认输。绝不可能。他不会的。嗯-hmm。后来，我很高兴他没有放弃。迈克尔向大家发表讲话。他拿到了披萨。
It's sitting there. I think we'd all like to eat it, but of course, Michael has to give it big speech first. And then he does what only Michael can do, which is he tells everybody the news. That he was supposed to keep to himself, which is that we're going out of business. Well, everyone has a pretty strong reaction to this news. Dwight goes out and kicks the Christmas tree down. Yeah. Ellie and Mindy shared on the commentary
它就放在那儿。我想我们大家都很想吃，但当然了，迈克尔必须先发表一番长篇大论。然后他做了只有迈克尔才做得到的事，那就是把这个消息告诉了所有人。本该由他自己保密的消息，也就是我们公司要倒闭了。好吧，大家对这个消息的反应相当强烈。德怀特走出去把圣诞树给踢倒了。是的。艾莉和明迪在评论音轨中分享说，
that the day we shot this scene when Dwight's kicking the tree down, the episode Niagara was airing that evening. And everyone wanted to wrap so we could get to Greg's to watch Niagara. I guess Greg had invited the whole cast over for a viewing party. So I dug in my digital clutter and I found the email invite. Oh my gosh! I totally remember this viewing party by the way. Yeah! He says, hey guys, please come to my house for a viewing party for Niagara at 730, October 8th.
在我们拍这场德怀特踢倒圣诞树的戏的当天晚上，《尼亚加拉》那一集正在播出。大家都想快点收工，这样就能去格雷格家看《尼亚加拉》了。我猜格雷格邀请了整个剧组去他家参加观影派对。所以我翻找了我数码垃圾堆，找到了那封电子邮件邀请函。哦天哪！顺便说一句，我完全记得这个观影派对。对！他说，嘿，伙计们，请在10月8日7点30分来我家参加《尼亚加拉》的观影派对。
Dinner and we will watch Jim and Pam get married. Love Greg. Well, he and his wife Suzyon threw this party. That was almost like a wedding reception. They had little M&Ms printed with Jim and Pam. And little napkins like you would get at a wedding. Yes, it was so sweet. They had amazing food.
有晚宴，我们一起看吉姆和帕姆结婚。爱你们的格雷格。好吧，他和他的妻子苏赞办了这场派对。那几乎就像是一场婚宴。他们定制了印有吉姆和帕姆名字的小M&M豆。还有你在婚礼上能见到的那种小纸巾。对，太温馨了。他们准备了超棒的食物。
It was really fun. The tables had, you know, the little confetti, you can sprinkle that had the little wedding bells. It was so cute. I totally remember going to that. I went with Lee. So just know while we were filming this conference room scene of Michael spilling the beans and Dwight kicking the tree,
真的太有趣了。桌上有那种可以撒的亮晶晶的小五彩纸屑，上面还有小婚礼钟。太可爱了。我完全记得去过那次派对。我是和李一起去的。所以大家要知道，当我们正在拍这场会议室里迈克尔说漏嘴、德怀特踢倒圣诞树的戏时，
we were like, all right, let's get these lines so we can make it to Greg's. Greg and Suzanne were always so generous. They invited us into their home many, many times over these nine years of doing the office. It was a really warm and personal touch. It bonded us from the beginning. It was really cool. They still are. Greg invited us all over for Sunday brunch and we all went. We did just recently. Just recently. Well, Michael tells everyone, listen, I'll get David on the phone so he can explain things. And Jim's like, I don't think so, Michael, I've been trying to reach him all day and he's not taking my calls. And Michael is like, I know
我们心里想的是，好了，赶紧把这些台词演完，好让我们能赶去格雷格家。格雷格和苏赞一直都非常慷慨。在拍摄《办公室》这九年的时间里，他们邀请我们去他们家里做客过非常多次。那种感觉非常温暖和人性化。从一开始就把我们紧紧联系在了一起。真的很酷。他们现在依然如此。格雷格邀请我们大家去吃周日早午餐，我们全都去了。我们不久前才去过。就在不久前。好吧，迈克尔告诉大家，听着，我把大卫的电话打通，这样他就能跟大家解释清楚了。然后吉姆说，我觉得不会吧，迈克尔，我一整天都在联系他，他根本不接我的电话。迈克尔却一副我知道
how to get a hold of him. He's proud of this. It's amazing. He knows where David's kids go to school. So first, he calls the school, pretends to be their pediatrician. Then, he gets patched through to David's secretary, and then he talks in his little girl voice. And pretends to be David's daughter. So, of course, when David answers the phone, he's like, what's up, sweetie?
怎么联系上他的表情。他对此感到很自豪。太惊人了。他知道大卫的孩子在哪所学校上学。所以首先，他给学校打电话，假装是他们的儿科医生。然后，他转接到大卫的秘书那里，接着他用他那种小女孩的声音说话。并假装是大卫的女儿。所以，理所当然地，当大卫接起电话时，他会说，怎么了，甜心？
Mm-hmm. Because David thinks it's his daughter who is at the pediatrician's office. Oh my God, Michael. I mean, it's kind of amazing. In Michael's office, we have, for the first time, the whole entire Dundermifflin bullpen and warehouse. Yes, all of us hovering over the speaker phone.
嗯-hmm。因为大卫以为那是正在儿科诊所的女儿。哦天哪，迈克尔。我的意思是，这简直绝了。在迈克尔的办公室里，我们第一次迎来了整个邓德米夫林的大办公室员工和仓库员工。是的，我们所有人都挤在扬声器电话旁。
David reveals, Michael, first of all, you were never supposed to tell everybody, but second of all, I wasn't talking about you. All of your jobs are safe. It's just this upper management. You would have thought the office won the Super Bowl. I know. Everyone goes nuts.
大卫透露，迈克尔，首先，你本不应该把这事告诉所有人；但其次，我说的根本不是你们。你们所有人的工作都很安全。只是高层管理人员而已。你可能会以为办公室赢得了超级碗。我知道。所有人都疯狂了。
Michael jumps off his desk and does this crowd surfing move. Mindy shared on the commentary that that was Steve's idea, that he thought it would be really fun if Michael dove into the crowd. We had a fan question from Kyle T. and Houston, Texas, who said, did y'all have a safety meeting for Michael's crowd dive? By the way, I want you to know, Kyle wrote y'all. Of course he did. Kyle from Texas. That's right, from Houston.
迈克尔从办公桌上跳下来，做了这个人群冲浪的动作。敏迪在幕后花絮里分享说，那是史蒂夫的主意，他觉得迈克尔跳进人群里一定会非常有趣。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的粉丝凯尔·T. 的提问，他说，你们为迈克尔的人群跳水开过安全会议吗？顺便说一句，我想让你们知道，凯尔用的是“y'all”（你们大家）。他当然用了。来自德克萨斯州的凯尔。没错，来自休斯顿。
H-town. Did y'all have a safety meeting for Michael's crowd dive? I appreciated that detail, by the way. We did have a safety meeting. Eric Sulkey was our stunt coordinator and Randy Cordray told us that he gave everyone direction on how to catch Steve's dive and how to lower him down to the ground safely.
H城。你们为迈克尔的人群跳水开过安全会议吗？顺便说一句，我很欣赏这个细节。我们确实开过安全会议。埃里克·苏尔基是我们的特技指导，兰迪·科德雷告诉我们，他向每个人交代了如何接住史蒂夫的跳水，以及如何安全地把他降落到地面上。
We also dressed two stunt players as warehouse workers and added them into the crowd. Randy said these burly stunt dudes were the main individuals involved in catching and protecting Steve and keeping him from crashing to the floor. Yeah, it wasn't me. It wasn't like, no me and Kate and you holding Steve up. Correct. Now folks, it's time for some karaoke. Yeah. This is where Dwight is singing Boulevard of Broken Dreams by Green Day.
我们还将两名特技演员打扮成仓库工人，把他们塞进人群里。兰迪说，这些身强力壮的特技猛男是负责接住和保护史蒂夫、防止他摔到地板上的主要人员。是的，不是我。可不是说，没有我和凯特还有你把史蒂夫托起来这回事。没错。好了各位，现在是卡拉OK时间。耶。这里德怀特正在唱绿日乐队的《Boulevard of Broken Dreams》（断梦大道）。
Andy joins in in some perfect harmony. Boulevard of Broken Dreams is from Green Day's 2004 album, American Idiot. So something that I know because I'm friends with Billy Joe Armstrong. I cannot say it enough. She's blushing again. I'm just so tickled every time I can say that. She's blushing again. Is that Billy had seen the office,
安迪加入进来，和声非常完美。《Boulevard of Broken Dreams》出自绿日乐队2004年的专辑《American Idiot》（美国傻瓜）。所以，我知道这件事是因为我和比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗是朋友。我怎么说都不嫌多。她又脸红了。每次我能说出这句话，我都觉得特别开心。她又脸红了。是比利看过了《办公室》，
but he recently in 2019 did a big rewatch of the whole series. Oh, nice. And I asked him, when you did your rewatch, did you remember that you had given us permission to use this song? Here's what he had to say. I was binge watching the office for the first time and I was watching that episode and then all of a sudden the song came on
但他最近在2019年对整部剧进行了大规模重温。哦，太棒了。我问他，当你重温这部剧的时候，你还记得你曾授权给我们使用这首歌吗？他是这么说的：我当时第一次狂刷《办公室》，我正在看那一集，然后突然这首歌就放了起来，
and I was completely taken by surprise. And like, I think my face started to get red and and Andy he he started singing harmonies which was almost like the because we do have a musical for American idiot and he sang the same exact harmony at that's in the musical so it was He sang the same exact harmony at that scene in the musical. So it was good. Well, I just love it that he was surprised by his own song. During that re-wine. I know, that's so sweet.
我完全被惊到了。而且，我觉得我的脸开始变红了，安迪他开始唱和声，这简直就像是……因为我们确实为《美国傻瓜》做过音乐剧，他在那一幕里唱的和声和音乐剧里完全一样，所以这真的很棒。他唱了那一幕在音乐剧里的完全相同的和声。所以这很棒。哦，我只是觉得他被自己的歌给惊到了，这太有意思了。在那次重温期间。我知道，这太可爱了。
Listen, I think we need to hear this. I think we need to hear Dwight and Andy singing Boulevard of Broken Dreams. Oh, for sure. Walk alone, Lee Road, only one that I have ever known. Don't know where it goes, but it's all to me. But I walk alone. It's true. We all walk alone.
听着，我觉得我们需要听听这个。我觉得我们需要听听德怀特和安迪唱《Boulevard of Broken Dreams》。哦，肯定的。独自走着，利路，我唯一知道的一条路。不知道它通往何方，但它对我而言就是全部。但我独自一人。没错。我们都独自一人。
My shadow, only one that walks beside me. I love it. I love hearing them. I could hear them do it like every day. It would make me happy singing that song. Mindy shared in the commentary that she absolutely loved this montage of Christmas kind of all coming together set to the backdrop of a non-Christmas song. Yes. And Jenna, I guess there was a musical interlude to the karaoke and Ed and Rain had to vamp during it. It's so funny. It's in the extended producer's cut. We have to hear their vamp. I mean, I know they already produce the musical version of American Idiot, but I'm saying if you bring it back to the stage, you might want to add this. Ed Edadane. You might want to.
我的影子，唯一走在我身旁的人。我太喜欢了。我喜欢听他们唱。我恨不得每天都能听到他们唱。唱这首歌会让我很开心。敏迪在幕后花絮里分享说，她非常喜欢这个圣诞节各种元素融合在一起的蒙太奇片段，背景音乐是一首非圣诞歌曲。是的。而且詹娜，我猜卡拉OK中间有一段音乐间奏，埃德和雷恩必须在那期间即兴发挥。太搞笑了。它在加长制作剪辑版里。我们必须听听他们的即兴发挥。我是说，我知道他们已经制作了音乐剧版的《American Idiot》，但我是说，如果你把它搬回舞台，你可能想加上这段。埃德·雷恩。你可能会想加。
I mean, pretty great. We've all been there. We've all picked a song for karaoke and then there's a big musical interlude and you're like, what do I do? Yes. I'm kind of bobbin' my head. I mean, Ed crushed it. Well there are just a bunch of scenes now of people enjoying Christmas.
我是说，相当棒。我们都经历过这种事。我们都为卡拉OK选了一首歌，然后来了一段超长的音乐间奏，你会想：我该干嘛？是的。我有点在晃脑袋。我是说，埃德表现炸裂。现在有一堆大家享受圣诞节的场景。
Everyone's getting gifts that are really meaningful to them. And finally Dwight is gonna get the last piece of his gift and realizes this whole time he's been making a nutcracker. Yes, of course, it's like a really cool nutcracker. We had a fan question from Lacey L. in Grand Prairie, Texas. Please, please tell me about Dwight's nutcracker. Who came up with it? Where did they find it?
每个人都得到了对他们意义非凡的礼物。最后，德怀特终于得到了他礼物的最后一部分，并意识到他这一整直都在做一个胡桃夹子。是的，当然，它就像一个非常酷的胡桃夹子。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州大草原城的蕾西·L. 的粉丝提问。求求你，快跟我讲讲德怀特的胡桃夹子。是谁想出来的？他们在哪里找到的？
Or did they have to create it? I have been looking for it for years. Lacey, I thought the same thing. I thought, can I get one of these? Well, Randy told me that this was not in the first shooting draft of the script. This whole runner was added later, and he believes that it was the master of the cold opens,
还是他们必须自己制作？我找了好多年了。蕾西，我当时也是这么想的。我想，我也能弄到一个吗？好吧，兰迪告诉我，这并没有出现在剧本的第一个拍摄初稿中。整个这条线是后来才加的，他相信这是冷开场大师，
Aaron Schur, who wrote this story arc, because Aaron became the point person that they went to to discuss the creation of this prop. Randy said when he and Phil first read this story arc, they assumed that this contraption was something the writers had seen on the internet somewhere, and they wanted to know where do they buy it. It turns out, and it did not exist anywhere. They made it up? Yeah. They made it up? Yeah. They made it up.
阿隆·舒尔，他写了这条故事线，因为阿隆成了他们讨论这个道具制作时去找的核心人物。兰迪说，当他和菲尔第一次读到这个故事线时，他们以为这个装置是编剧们在互联网的某个地方看到的，他们想知道在哪里可以买到它。事实证明，它根本不存在于任何地方。他们自己捏造的？是的。他们自己捏造的？是的。他们自己捏造的。
I even went to the rewrite of the script, and there is no scripted description of this machine. So Phil needed to conceptualize, design, and build a working nutcracker prop that looked like it could have been a gun, and he had less than a week to do it. Phil Shay. This is why he was always running, folks.
我甚至去看了剧本的重写版，上面对这台机器没有任何剧本描述。所以菲尔需要概念化、设计并制造一个能运转的胡桃夹子道具，看起来得像一把枪，而且他只有不到一周的时间来完成它。菲尔·谢伊。这就是为什么他总是跑来跑去，各位。
Phil went to his go-to props manufacturing house, the hand prop room. The team at that facility, Randy said, was understandably freaked out at the very short time span that they had to create this prop. They told Phil to tell Randy to open up the company checkbook. They were gonna have to put a full team of engineers and builders basically around the clock to get this done in time. Randy said to their credit they did a masterful job all in this prop cost about $19,000. Also, it was a one-off.
菲尔去了他常用的道具制造厂——手提道具室。兰迪说，该设施的团队对他们制作这个道具的极短时间感到惊恐万状，这是可以理解的。他们告诉菲尔去让兰迪打开公司的支票簿。为了按时完成任务，他们得安排一整支由工程师和建造师组成的团队基本上连轴转。兰迪说，平心而论，他们做了一项大师级的工作，这个道具总共花费了大约19,000美元。另外，这是个孤品。
about $19,000. Also, it was a one-off. He said to the best of his knowledge that NBC Universal Marketing People never made replicas of this for online sales. They should have. They still can. I'm just saying, this would be a hot item at the holidays. Yeah. Do you know how many people would buy this? I would. I would too. But do I have to put it together? Oh no. Oh no. What if you do? That would be the ultimate. I know.
大约19,000美元。另外，这是个孤品。据他所知，NBC环球营销部门从来没有为网络销售制作过这东西的复制品。他们本该制作的。他们现在还可以。我只是说，这将是节假日的爆款商品。是的。你知道有多少人会买这个吗？我会的。我也会。但我得自己把它组装起来吗？哦不。哦不。万一你要呢？那可就太终极了。我知道。
You know, this story reminds me of something that I had a makeup artist tell me once. She said, there is a saying in this business. It's called fast, cheap, or good. And you can only have two of the three things. It can be fast and cheap, but it's not going to look good. It can be cheap and good, but it's not going to be fast. If you want it to be both fast and good, it's not going to be cheap.
你知道，这个故事让我想起了化妆师曾经对我说过的一句话。她说，这行里有句名言。叫做：快、便宜、好。你只能三选二。它可以又快又便宜，但它不会好看。它可以又便宜又好，但它不会快。如果你想既快又好，那它就不会便宜。
That was the case with our Nutcracker. Fast and good. It was not cheap. Not going to not cheap. Nope. Well, Jenna Mindy also spoke about this scene on the commentary. And she said it was a last minute rewrite that it was not in her original draft.
我们的胡桃夹子就是这种情况。又快又好。它可不便宜。不可能……不便宜。才不。好吧，詹娜，敏迪也在评论音轨里谈到了这个场景。她说这是一个最后一分钟才重写的场景，它不在她的最初草稿里。
She said it was written by Aaron Schur and Charlie Grandi. And Mindy said Phil Shea went above and beyond, especially because it was a last minute prop gag. She also commented that it was a note from Greg to add a Dwight Michael storyline to this episode, and it pays off so nicely at the end. It's a moment of redemption for Michael. Yes. Yeah, he knows Dwight so well.
她说这是由阿隆·舒尔和查理·格兰迪写的，敏迪说菲尔·谢伊做得超出了预期，特别是考虑到这是一个临时赶出来的道具梗。她还评论说，这是格雷格提出的一条笔记，要在这一集里增加一条德怀特和迈克尔的故事线，结果在最后得到了非常好的回报。对迈克尔来说这是一个完成救赎的时刻。是的。是的，他太了解德怀特了。
Yeah, it's a good note. Yeah. Well, the party is wrapping up. Everyone is leaving for the night. They're walking out into the parking lot. There's snow. It feels so Christmassy and festive. That's right. You know, as you're walking out, Angela, I don't know if you noticed this, but we got a fan question from Kelsey D and Orlando, Florida. I noticed when everyone is leaving the office, Angela slips, and Darryl is there to help her. Did Angela actually slip or was that planned? Because I love that moment, it's so cute and sweet between Angela and Darryl.
是的，这是个好点子。好吧，派对快要结束了。每个人都在准备离开。他们走向停车场。下雪了。感觉太有圣诞气氛、太喜庆了。没。你知道，当你走出去的时候，安吉拉，我不知道你有没有注意到这个，但我们收到了来自佛罗里达州奥兰多的粉丝凯尔西·D. 的提问。我注意到当每个人离开办公室时，安吉拉滑倒了，达里尔过去帮了她。安吉拉是真的滑倒了还是那是计划好的？因为我太喜欢那个瞬间了，安吉拉和达里尔之间太可爱、太温馨了。
Okay, Kelsey, I did actually trip. And I grabbed Craig's arm. So that quick moment you're seeing, that's us. Aw. arm. So that quick moment you're seeing, that's us. We're not in character. And I think rain must have seen it and improvised the line as Dwight. Watch out, it's slippery out here. Because that line is not in the shooting draft. Me slipping and tripping is obviously not in the shooting draft. So yes, that's just me and Craig and thank goodness he was there. I guess I turned my ankle or something. Well, all of a sudden we hear something.
好吧，凯尔西，我其实是真的摔了。我抓住了克雷格的胳膊。所以你看到的那个短暂瞬间，那就是我们。噢。胳膊。所以你看到的那个短暂瞬间，那就是我们。我们当时没有在角色状态中。而且我想雷恩一定看到了，然后作为德怀特即兴发挥了那句台词：小心点，外面很滑。因为那句台词不在拍摄初稿里。我滑倒和绊倒显然也不在拍摄初稿里。所以是的，那只是我和克雷格，谢天谢地他在那儿。我猜我崴了脚踝什么的。好吧，突然我们听到了一些声音。
It's drummers. It's 12 drummers drumming. This is Aaron's final Christmas present from Andy. Andy is on the symbols. He starts dancing. It's so festive. We had a fan catch from Rachel I in Phoenix, Arizona, who said there are only 11 people in the drum line.
是鼓手。12个击鼓的鼓手。这是阿隆从安迪那里收到的最后一份圣诞礼物。安迪在敲钹。他开始跳舞。太喜庆了。我们收到了来自亚利桑那州菲尼克斯的粉丝蕾切尔·I. 的捉虫反馈，她说鼓号队里只有11个人。
Was Andy meant to be the 12th person? Yes, Rachel, he was the 12th percussionist in this drum line. We also got a question from Maria S. in Austin, Texas, who asked, what was the process for choosing this group that played the 12 drummers drumming? And Emily B. from Torrance, California said, I want to give a shout out to the RCC marching tigers who are the drum line featured in this episode. RCC has a fall marching band program and also a winter percussion program that is one of the best independent performance
安迪本来是第12个人吗？是的，蕾切尔，他就是这支鼓号队里的第12位打击乐手。我们还收到了来自德克萨斯州奥斯汀的玛丽亚·S. 的提问，她问，选择这支演奏“12个击鼓鼓手”的乐队的过程是怎样的？加利福尼亚州托兰斯的埃米莉·B. 说，我要向RCC行进之虎（RCC marching tigers）致敬，他们是这一集里出镜的鼓号队。RCC有一个秋季行进乐队项目，还有一个冬季打击乐项目，这是全国最好的独立表演
groups in the country. You can see more about them at RCC drums on IG. She said my husband is the battery captain head and a ranger for the group which means he writes the music and teaches the students how to play their instruments so it is always so fun when I see RCC on a show they've been on parks and rec too. Emily thank you so much for sending that in. Randy confirmed that everything Emily said is correct. He said that he would always reach out to a woman named Christine Day. She is a music contractor. And she finds musical on screen performers.
团体之一。你可以在IG上的 @RCC drums 了解更多关于他们的信息。她说我的丈夫是电池组（编者注：行进乐队中的打击乐声部）队长兼该团体的游骑兵，这意味着他负责写谱子并教学生们如何演奏乐器，所以每当我在节目中看到RCC时总是觉得非常有趣，他们也上过《公园与游憩》。埃米莉，非常感谢你发来这些。兰迪证实了埃米莉所说的一切都是正确的。他说他总是会联系一个叫克里斯蒂娜·戴的女士。她是一位音乐经纪人。她负责寻找荧幕上的音乐表演者。
Randy said there was just no one better than her. He actually said quote, she is well known across the industry for her cheerful professionalism and ability to aggrasp the essence of a script and the showrunners intent, all in including Christine's fee, the marching band cost us $9,950. Well, I will put the RCC drums, Instagram and our stories so you guys can see what they're up to. I loved learning all of that. Well, we had so much fun on this night with this marching band.
兰迪说真的没有人比她更优秀了。他甚至原话引用说：“她在整个行业中以其开朗的专业精神以及对剧本精髓和剧集运作人意图的敏锐把握而闻名，所有费用，包括克里斯蒂娜的酬金在内，行进乐队让我们花费了9,950美元。”好吧，我会把RCC鼓号队的Instagram放到我们的快拍里，这样你们就能看到他们在忙些什么了。我很喜欢了解所有这些。好吧，我们在那天晚上和这支行进乐队玩得太开心了。
I'll never forget it. I mean, we got to stay late. We always love to stay late. We did it so rarely. And then we had snow. We had snow with this like amazing drumming as a backdrop. Incredible. I asked Randy if we used snow business again.
我永远不会忘记。我是说，我们得留得很晚。我们总是很喜欢留得很晚。我们很少这样做。然后我们下雪了。我们伴随着这种惊艳的鼓点背景下迎来了雪。太不可思议了。我问兰迪我们是不是又用了“造雪业务”（Snow Business）公司。
And he said, no, not this time. It was Ron Nerry's group, A&A Special Effects in Van Ayes. He said, in order to get that snow in our parking lot, they had to call this place Union Ice in North Hollywood, and they brought two semi-tracker trailer rigs full of ice. Two! Wow. And then Ron's team put the ice through an industrial chipper and it like, shot it into the air. He said, we shot that scene on a Friday night
他说，不，这次没有。那是罗恩·内里的团队，位于凡奈斯的A&A特效公司。他说，为了让停车场下起雪来，他们不得不打电话给北好莱坞的这家名为“联合冰块”（Union Ice）的地方，他们拉来了两辆满载冰块的半挂货车拖车。两辆！哇哦。然后罗恩的团队把冰块放进工业碎冰机里，然后把它像这样喷射到空中。他说，我们在一个周五晚上拍摄了那个场景，
and it had been 78 degrees that day. He said all of the snow effects for this episode, filling the parking lot as well as that little snowfall behind our windows that cost $36,000 For snow for snow on a day where it was almost 80 degrees You know, it's always fascinating to me when Randy shares with us how much something cost in an episode because It's like he had to budget all of that. Yeah, in the budget for each episode does not change week to week, but the demands change. Yeah.
而那天足足有78华氏度（约25.5摄氏度）。他说这一集所有的造雪特效，填满停车场以及我们窗户后面那场小雪，花费了36,000美元。为了在几乎快80度的一天造雪……你知道，每当兰迪跟我们分享某集里某个东西花了多少钱时，我总是觉得很着迷，因为这就好像他必须把所有这些都列入预算。是的，每集的预算周与周之间是不会变的，但需求在变。是的。
So he would have this elaborate spreadsheet and he would have to figure out how to make all these little details happen. He needed to get the geese and the swans and the special prop and the snow and the drum line and make it all cost the same as an episode that didn't even have all those things. Right. It's really fascinating to me. But you know, I love a spreadsheet. I know you do.
所以他会有一张制作精细的电子表格，他必须想办法让所有这些小细节都得以实现。他需要弄来大雁、天鹅、特殊的道具、雪和鼓号队，还要让这一切的花费和一集根本没有这些东西的剧集一模一样。没错。这真的让我觉得很着迷。但你知道的，我就是喜欢电子表格。我知道你喜欢。
Well, you know, Mindy was talking in the commentary about the scene about how hard Ed had to work as Andy doing the running man dancing with the symbols and we did a lot of takes. And she was like, do you guys remember he was like sweating? He did such a good job. I know.
好吧，你知道的，敏迪在评论音轨里谈到这个场景时说，埃德作为安迪，一边敲钹一边跳“奔跑人”舞蹈，工作有多么辛苦，我们拍了好多条。她当时就说：你们还记得吗，他当时一直在流汗？他做得太棒了。我知道。
Well, that is how the episode ends. However, we got a fan question from Katie G in Greenville, South Carolina. In the DVD commentary, Mindy teases that Greg had an alternate ending for this episode, but she was not gonna tell us what it was. She kinda just says, you'll have to ask Greg. Yeah. What was the ending Katie wants to know?
好吧，这一集就是这样结束的。不过，我们收到了来自南卡罗来纳州格林ville的粉丝凯蒂·G. 的提问。在DVD评论音轨中，敏迪打趣说格雷格为这一集准备了一个替代结局，但她当时不打算告诉我们那是什么。她基本上只是说：你们得去问格雷格。是的。凯蒂想知道结局到底是什么？
Well, Katie, I heard this conversation too. It happens as the credits, you know, are going at the end. Mm-hmm. And our editor, Claire Scanlon, jumps in and says she actually cut out the scene. Well, listen, we wanted to get to the bottom of this. We wanted to mom detectives this and actually solve this one. Will we do it? I started by reaching out to Greg Daniels, and he did not remember. I reached out to Claire Scanlon, who enlisted the help of Rob Burnett, the office writers assistant.
好吧，凯蒂，我也听到了这段对话。它发生在片尾字幕滚动的时候。嗯哼。我们的剪辑师克莱尔·斯坎伦插话说，她实际上把那个场景剪掉了。好吧，听着，我们想要刨根问底。我们想化身“妈妈侦探”，真正把这个谜题解开。我们做到了吗？我首先联系了格雷格·丹尼尔斯，但他不记得了。我联系了克莱尔·斯坎伦，她在《办公室》编剧助理罗布·伯内特的协助下找到了线索。
Rob went through his digital clutter and found a tag in a late rewrite of the script, and then Claire found the footage. That's right, it is a scene where Pam sees Oscar and Matt walking away from the drumline group. They're going to go back inside. Pam follows them in, but then quickly comes back out of the building, and it is clear that she has seen them making out.
罗布翻找了他电脑里的数字杂物，在剧本的一个后期重写版本中找到了一个尾声小标签，然后克莱尔找到了这段素材。没错，那是帕姆看到奥斯卡和马特从鼓号队旁边走开的一个场景。他们要回里面去。帕姆跟着他们进去，但随后又很快从建筑里出来了，很明显她看到他们在旁若无人地亲热。
So that was the surprise ending that Matt and Oscar hook up at work. Now this is very funny to me, Angela, because Pam has now caught Phyllis and Bob in a bathroom at lunch, and now she has caught Matt and Oscar in the hall closet. I mean, how many people are getting it on at work or during work hours? Well, we haven't even brought up Kelly and Ryan. And then of course, Dwight and Angela don't get me started. But Pam and Jim had a pretty steamy kiss one time after hours. Well that's true.
所以这就是那个惊喜结局：马特和奥斯卡在工作时好上了。安吉拉，这让我觉得非常搞笑，因为帕姆之前已经在午休时把菲利斯和鲍勃堵在洗手间里，现在她又把马特和奥斯卡堵在走廊的壁橱里了。我的天，到底有多少人在工作场所或者工作时间内胡搞啊？好吧，我们甚至还没提凯利和瑞安呢。然后当然还有德怀特和安吉拉——别让我开启这个话题。但是帕姆和吉姆有一次在下班后也有过一个相当火辣的吻。好吧，这倒也是。
Well you know later it's sort of speculated that Jim and Pam make their second baby at work. Oh god. It's on Valentine's Day. Right. And then Michael and Holly are in the stairwell. Yeah, they forgot to lock the door. That leads to the entire robbery of crime aid.
好吧，你知道后来有种说法是吉姆和帕姆在工作时造了他们的第二个孩子。噢天哪。是在情人节那天。没错。然后迈克尔和霍利在楼梯间里。是的，他们忘了锁门。这导致了后来整个“犯罪援助”（Crime Aid）抢劫案的发生。
I mean, this place is a hot bed of hookups. A hot bed of hookups. Wait a second. Did mom detectives just solve one? We solved one, and I feel very good about solving one. I am so excited that we got to the bottom of that Claire and Rob. Thank you so much. Yes, they sent us this footage, you guys.
我是说，这个地方简直就是乱搞的温床。乱搞的温床。等一下。妈妈侦探刚才是不是破获了一起案件？我们破获了一起，而且我觉得破获这起案件感觉棒极了。我太兴奋了，我们终于查清了真相，多亏了克莱尔和罗布。非常感谢。是的，他们把这段素材发给我们了，各位。
It's pretty special. The cast ends up in a snowball fight once again. Yeah, it really brought me back. What an amazing time in our lives, Jenna. And how lucky we get to rewatch this together. I know. It's bringing back all of these more memories for me. I just love it. I love doing this podcast every week. And we love it when you guys reach out to us and tell us
这真的挺特别的。演员们最后又一次陷入了一场打雪仗中。是的，这真的把我带回过去了。我们生命中多么不可思议的一段时光啊，詹娜。我们能一起重温这部剧是多么幸运啊。我知道。这为我唤回了所有这些更多的回忆。我太喜欢了。我喜欢每周都做这个播客。我们也喜欢你们联系我们并告诉我们
different things that mean something to you. It brightens our whole day. Well, thank you for all of your fan questions. Just a reminder, you submit fan questions by going to officeladies.com. We have a little folder you can click on and you can submit for any episode by folder. Jenna's very excited about the folder, Skys. I am. Very excited. Thanks once again to Randy Cordray, Claire Scanlon, Rob Burnett, Greg Daniels, Joy about
对你们意义重大的各种事情。这照亮了我们的整一天。好吧，谢谢你们所有的粉丝提问。提醒一下，你们可以通过访问 officeladies.com 来提交粉丝提问。我们有一个小文件夹供你点击，你可以按文件夹为任意一集提交提问。詹娜对这个文件夹感到非常兴奋，各位。我是。非常兴奋。再次感谢兰迪·科德雷、克莱尔·斯坎伦、罗布·伯内特、格雷格·丹尼尔斯、乔·阿布
four, and my friend, my personal friend who I can text anytime I want. Lead singer of Green Day. Really joy, I'm sorry. You guys have a great week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Ear Wolf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher.
四世，还有我的朋友，我可以随时发短信联系的个人朋友。绿日乐队的主唱。真的啦，乔，我很抱歉。你们过个愉快的一周。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Ear Wolf、詹妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。
Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Keeper and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Ratten. For add free versions of office ladies, go to Stitcher Premium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium premium use code office. Thank you everyone for listening to the special presentation of secret Santa. I can't believe Angela that in the new year we're going to be going into season 9 and we only have one more Christmas episode left. Ever. Ever.
我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基珀，副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·拉滕的《Rubber Tree》。想要无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 Stitcher Premium.com。想要获得 Stitcher Premium 的一个月免费试用，请使用代码 office。谢谢大家收听这期关于“秘密圣诞老人”的特别节目。安吉拉，我真不敢相信在新的一年里我们将进入第九季，而且我们只剩最后一个圣诞节剧集了。有史以来。有史以来。
I'm the office. I know. And thank you to State Farm for supporting the show. State Farm is there to help you feel supported with the coverage you need for your car, your home, and even boats and motorcycles are these and other things that matter to you. They make insurance easy. They have options to fit your unique needs, which means you can talk to your agent to choose the coverage you need, have coverage options to protect the things you
我在办公室里。我知道。感谢 State Farm 对本节目的支持。State Farm 随时准备为您提供所需的保障，涵盖您的汽车、房屋，甚至是船只和摩托车，以及对您重要的这些和其他事物。他们让保险变得简单。他们有适合您独特需求的各种选项，这意味着您可以与您的代理人沟通以选择您需要的保障，拥有可以保护您
value most, you can file a claim right on the State Farm mobile app and reach a real person when you need to talk to someone. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. State Farm is there. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
最珍视事物的保障选项，您可以直接在 State Farm 移动应用程序上提交理赔，并在需要与人交谈时联系到真人。就像好邻居一样，State Farm 一直在您身边。State Farm 一直在您身边。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。